COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE TO ORDER
AND- PLEASE BEAR WITH ME FOR
SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD BEFORE- IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND TODAY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE PRESENT IN
THE HEARING ROOM ALREADY
PRESENT ON MYSELF. AND SENATOR
MEN AND WE EXPECTS AND CONTROL
BALK SHORTLY. ARE THOSE
PROVIDING CUSTOMER BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
POLICE SELECTOR ON ME BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAK. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOUR READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TODAY. THE
TWO HEARING ROOMS ARE THIS ONE
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND
THE BACK ONE IS ROOM ONE
TWELVE. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT IS DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN
NINE EIGHT SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND ORDERED
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE
NOTE ARE ONCE AGAIN THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU HEAR FROM YOU
CLEARLY AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
YESTERDAY ARE WE HAD A HEARING
ON HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE HAD
SOME DIFFICULTY. IN THAT WE RAN
OVER AND I HAD TO LIMIT-
TESTIMONY AT THE END TO THIRTY
SECONDS AND RESTORED PEOPLE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHEN I TURNED
HEARING SO. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
TODAY WE HEAR FROM EVERYBODY-
THAT'S MAKING PRESENTATIONS BUT
IF PEOPLE GO ON FOR AN
EXTENSIVE PERIOD OF TIME I WILL
INTERRUPT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
GET THROUGH THESE ITEMS TODAY
AND WE HAVE TO GET. TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH WILL BE AT
THE END OF ALL THE ITEMS WE
HEAR. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
COVER THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
PROPOSALS RELATED TO K. TWELVE
AND EARLY EDUCATION. AND ALSO
THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS. NO VOTES WILL
BE TAKEN TODAY. THIS IS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S MY
REVISIONS TO THE BUDGET AND
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WILL CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE
DISCUSSION AND COMMENTARY
TODAY. BEFORE WE TAKE DECISIONS
AND ACTIONS ON BUDGET ITEMS IN
THE FUTURE HEARING. AS I SAID
EARLIER PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
AT THE END OF THE HEARING ONCE
WE'VE COMPLETED ALL DISCUSSION.
MMHM LET ME JUST ASK- SENATOR
MEANT YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE WE BEGIN THE HEARING
OKAY THEN LET'S GO TO- ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS WE HAVE AS- PANELISTS
GABRIELA CHAVEZ. FROM THE DA
FOR. BRIANNA BRUNCHES AVAILABLE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JULIO MARTINEZ IS HERE FROM THE
TREASURE EDGAR CABRAL IS HERE
FROM THE BELLAGIO AND
COLLEAGUES IS HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE WILL
GO IN THAT ORDER SO WHEN ISSUE
NUMBER ONE CHILD CARE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS. WILL BEGIN WITH
GABRIELA CHAVEZ AND- WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THE MORNING CARE
AND MEMBERS THAT RELY TRAVIS
WITH AT THE OF- FINANCED. OKAY
BUT CHIU THE MAYOR OF THE
PROVIDE APPROXIMATELY TWO OR
ONE TIME FOR ON THE BROUGH PLAN
ACT OF TWO ONE FIVE IN THE
BUDGET YOU IN ESSENCE A HIGH
SEVEN MILLION GOING FUND
BEGINNING. TO TWO TO TWENTY
THREE. TO ESTABLISH KERR HE
SAID CAN. FOR ALL CAREER E.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ASK FIND BY
LOCAL BY FOR MORE. WHICH
SUFFERED IN BED FOR COST USED
HOMELESS STUDENTS. AND ALL IN
THE PALM SCHOOL AND FOR SUCCESS
COHORTS OF THIS IS. ASKED
ENTERED FIRST GRADE. QUALIFY
AND THE STUDENTS WERE AT THE OF
HUNDRED. AND YOU. IF YOUR
QUESTION PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THEN WE'LL GO TO JULIO
MARTINEZ FROM THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE- GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN-
I BELIEVE I'M HERE ALSO JUST
ANSWER ANY QUESTION YOU MAY
HAVE. RIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO EDGAR CABRAL FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. IT'S GOOD MORNING BOTH
THE L. A. R. BIG WE WERE JUST
NOT A THE STATE YOUR AT THE
PROPOSED OVER THE NEW PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE CREATED INTO
NINETEEN UNDER THE SKY
INVESTMENT WORK CALL THE KALKA
PROGRAM. SCHOLARSHIP IT'S GOOD
TO LAUNCH TO SEE AND PROVIDER
STEVEN ACCOUNT- YOU DEPOSIT OUR-
EVERY MORNING CALIFORNIA THE
PROPOSAL BETWEEN FIVE DOLLARS.
IF LEGISLATURE DOES WHICH
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR
COLLEGE ACCOUNTS THE BUDGET
YEAR IT COULD CONSIDER. CALC
WILL ALLOWED LEVERAGES PROGRAM
THAN CREATING A COMPLETE
PROGRAM. HAVING MORE PROGRAM-
ONE THINKING THAT. ARE FOR
FAMILIES NAVIGATE- TO MAKE IT
MORE FOR YOU PROGRAM. YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN REMOVED ONLY
GARNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. SHARE NO COMMENTS
FROM CD AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY FROM. MY ADMONITION ABOUT
BEING BRIEF WAS TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY. THANK YOU- LET ME
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
QUESTION TO BEGIN WITH AND THAT
IS IN ESSENCE RESPONDING TO THE
CONCERN THAT WAS EXPRESSED BY
THE OHIO. A WHY ARE WE CREATING
A SECOND STATE PROGRAM WHY NOT
BUILD OFF OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
WHICH REPLACES. HAVE
ELIGIBILITY IN PLACE. THERE'S
ALSO SEVERAL LOCAL PROGRAMS HOW
WOULD ALL THESE OPTIONS WORK
TOGETHER FOR FAMILIES. I REALLY
TRAVIS BUT THE BOMBING OF
FINANCE- TRANSLATING YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION- THE CURRENT
PROGRAM- IT'S- AT THE GRANT
PROGRAM THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
DOES NOT INTERACT WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THAT SAY WE RECOGNIZE
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS FOR
BETTER LINKING TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND WE WELCOME I
CONTINUE CONVERSATION TO THE
TOPIC OVER THE COMING WEEKS. I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. ANY PROVIDES A LONG
TERM- FUNDING FOR THIS ACCOUNT.
AND I HAVE A HAND FROM YOUR
COLLEAGUE. SO WHAT WE RECOGNIZE
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER AT THE
BILL ABBEY COME I WOULD KNOW
THAT THE PROGRAM PROVIDER.
RATHER AND THEN THE REVISION
INCLUDE ONGOING FUNDING WHEREAS
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM. ALL KIDS AS AN EXAM
WHERE THE ROOF OF ONE TYPE OR
SO EASY THIS IS OTHER I LOVE MY
CAR COLLEAGUE THAT DOESN'T LONG
SOLUTION. TO THAT. WELL I A-
BUT FOR- ONE JUST BECAUSE- THAT.
THAT IF A FAMILY IS CHOOSING TO
COMPLETE THE FREE AND REDUCED
MEAL. APPRISED ME OF PAPERWORK.
OR IT IS ENSURED THAT THEIR KID
IS DESIGNATED AS AN ENGLISH
LEARNER THEY'RE ALREADY MOVING
INTO THE SYSTEM IN CERTAIN WAYS
AND I APPRECIATE. MS CHAVEZ'S
COMMENT ABOUT THIS IS A
CONVERSATION SO I JUST WANT TO
ANNOUNCED THIS IS A
CONVERSATION WE WILL WANT TO
HAVE. A BECAUSE WHAT IF THIS
GOES AHEAD WE THINK THERE ARE
SOME STREAMLINED WAYS TO DO
THIS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT PROPOSALS SO LET ME
JUST ANNOUNCED THAT. AN ENEMY
THE QUESTION I WANT TO ASK. IS
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL. AND IT'S-
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE GOING
INTO DEBT EXTENSIVELY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WHY ARE WE
PRIORITIZING FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR KIDS THAT ARE YEARS
AND YEARS AWAY FROM COLLEGE
BOB- FOR REFORMING THE STUDENT
AID PROGRAM AND HELPING PEOPLE
THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH
COLLEGE DEBT RIGHT NOW. THEN I
WOULD START WITH FINANCE. I WAS
WITH THE FINAL FINANCED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CHANGE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION CHAIR- YES
THE PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON THE
LONG TERM INVESTMENT. FOR LIVE
WHERE PLACING ONLY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS YOU KNOW
WHAT HOPING THAT THEY
INVESTMENT GROUP WILL POST
SATURDAY STUDENT WELL WHEN THE
PERSON ATTENDS COLLEGE. IT IS
ALSO THE MENTALITY OF A STUDENT
WHO MAYBE THE PARENTS DON'T
HAVE A CHECKING ACCOUNT. OR
DON'T EVEN GO TO A BANK BUT
THEN THEY CAN'T NOW HAS AT IN
MIND SAYING THAT THERE IS SOME
COLLEGE SAVINGS FOR HIS FUTURE
OR FUTURE- WE ALSO WANT A POINT
JUST. POINT OUT THAT THE
CURRENT BUDGET AND THE MANY
REVISIONS FOCUSED ON
INVESTMENTS THAT MAY BE A ONE
TIME FUNDING. BUT COULD
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE LONG TERM-
BENEFITS SUCH AS A STUDENT
HOUSING THAT COVERS MORE OF THE.
OVERALL COST OF THE STUDENT. R.
L. DO YOU HAVE SOME. AS WELL.
IT'S A BIG I WAS NORTH EARNED
QUESTION A CENTERS GOING TO BE
BALLOTS ONE KIND OF BIG
QUESTION ABOUT HOW TO PROVIDE
INDEED THIS ONE OF MANY WAYS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS- WHO ARE PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION ITSELF- ON
ANOTHER APPROACH WOULD BE AS
YOU MENTIONED PROVIDING NO
BUILDING UP YOUR EXISTING
FINANCIAL PROGRAMS LET LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHEN THEY ARE
READY TO ENTER HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. AND HOW MANY MORE OF
THOSE. COSTS ARE COVERED BY THE
STATE. I CALLED. THAT- HOME.
THESE DO NOT HAVE TO BE MUTE
EXCLUSIVE BAND OF THIS IS A
VERY VALID AND GOOD CONCEPT AND
I KNOW AND ONE OF MY COUNTIES
IN THE DISTRICT- THERE'S AN
ATTEMPT TO DO OUR CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT AT A MUCH MORE SMALLER
LEVEL TO TRY TO. TO ACCOMPLISH
THE SAME OBJECTIVE OBJECTIVE
AND I THINK WE'RE REALLY
COMMITTED TO REFORMING THE
STUDENT AID AND SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE ALL THESE
THINGS WORK TOGETHER AND NOT
CHOICE SO ARE THERE WILL BE
CONVERSATIONS TO COME- MISTER
BETTER SENATOR MEANT DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS MR IS ALSO
FINE- LET ME- YES FOLLOW UP ON
YOUR COMMENTS. I GUESS I YOU
PERCENT A QUESTION- I WAS
UNCLEAR FROM READING THE
DESCRIPTION OF THIS PROGRAM
WHETHER THIS WOULD BE MORE
ORIENTED AS A DEPOSITORY TYPE-
FUND OR WHETHER IT WOULD BE.
INVESTED IN EQUITIES AND OKAY
INDEX FUNDS AND OTHER-
SECURITIES OUT IN THE MARKET.
PROBABLY FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OR ANYONE WHO HAVE HAD
A ROLE IN DESIGNING THIS MAYBE
COULD JUST. ELUCIDATE FOR ME
LIKE WHAT WHAT'S THE PROGRAM
LOOK LIKE IS IT IS IT GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT HAS. YOU KNOW
MORE LIKE BANKRATE'S AND IT'S
SAFE FOR WILL BE SOMETHING THAT
MAYBE A LITTLE RISKIER BECAUSE
AND A HIGHER YIELD INVESTMENTS.
SORRY OUT OF RENT THE APARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE DO THINK THAT
THAT THE AYE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT- PROGRAM WELL WE WOULD
DEFINITELY BE WORKING WITH OUR-
COLLEAGUES WERE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD OF THAT VALLEY FAIR
INVESTMENT BOARD. I DO WORK OUT
THE DETAILS ON EXACTLY HOW THE
INVESTMENTS WAY THAT WOULD
ALLOW. YEAH I MEAN I WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT YOU KNOW I PUT A
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR OPEN A
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR BANK
ACCOUNT FOR MY KID ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE TOTAL AMOUNT IN THAT
ACCOUNT AND I WAS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THREE DOLLARS. WITH
WITH. THE RIGHT. BEING THEY ARE-
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A FAIR.
WAY TO BUILD WELL. I OKAY.
ECHOED FOR ALERTS. THIS IS. A
REALLY IMPORTANT. BUILDING
WEALTH DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES AND CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR IS A VEXING PUBLIC
POLICY PROBLEM. AND I APPLAUD
THIS APPROACH. BUT I THINK THAT
WE PROBABLY WANT TO LOOK MORE
TO WHAT. THE SCHOLAR SHARE THE
FIVE TWENTY NINE TYPE PROGRAMS
ARE DOING- BUT THAT GETS TO MY
SECOND QUESTION WHICH IS. IF
WE'RE GOING TO KIND OF TAKE.
YOU BACK ON THE SCHOLARSHIP
CARE. WHY MAKE ANY. OR NOT DO
YOU EXISTING. TO TRY TO-
PROVIDE THIS FUNDING I KNOW
IT'S ALWAYS COOL TO MAKE A NEW
PROGRAM. BUT A NEW PROGRAM
COMES WITH NEW ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS- A IN THE OF THE BUILDING
FROM THE GROUND UP AND- IT
SEEMS LIKE THOSE PATHWAYS
ALREADY EXIST FOR DISTRIBUTING
THESE FUNDS TO CHILDREN
AFFECTIONATELY. THROUGH THE
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM SO I WOULD.
I GUESS I'D BE INTERESTED IN
YOUR REACTION AND. AND HEARING
WHETHER YOU'RE OPEN TO. YOU
KNOW TRYING TO USE SOME OF THE-
KIDS ARE OR OTHERPATHWAYS
RATHER THAN BUILDING SOMETHING
BRAND NEW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SENATORS- WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE YOUR FEEDBACK TO OUR
MANAGEMENT TEAM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GREAT OF CONDENSING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS HELLO LET ME
THANK THE PANEL AND- JUST DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT THIS WILL BE
A CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD
JUST AS I SAID EARLIER AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING IT SO WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE PEOPLE THAT PERCENT
TODAY. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS OUR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MAY
REVISION OVERVIEW. OUR THREE
PANELISTS ARE ERIN A READY UP
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CAN COUPON FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND ALLIE
GARNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WILL TAKE PEOPLE IN
THAT ORDER AND TO BEGIN WITH
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS THANK YOU
ARENARIA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HERE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE- AN OVERVIEW
OF OUR PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY OF
THIS WITH. THE ISSUE OF BREVITY
SO THANK YOU. NO PROBLEM YOU
LET ME KNOW AFTER HOW IT WENT-
SO WORLD PROVIDED THERE IS AN
AFTER I WILL LET YOU KNOW YEAH.
THERE WILL BE THERE WILL BE-
WITH STRONG REVENUE INCREASES
AS EVERYONE HAS HEARD ABOUT
OVER THE TWENTY TWENTY. BUDGET
ACT LEVELS- THAT WE ASSUMED AT
THAT TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND IS UP A TOTAL OF
MORE THAN FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
COMPARED TO THE OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT PROCESS THREE
YEAR PERIOD. AND ALMOST SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
RESOURCES TO PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND OVER-
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ACROSS THAT
SAME THREE YEAR PERIOD. AND
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
STILL IN A TEST ONE IN EACH OF
THOSE YEARS I IT WILL TAKE.
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS FOR EVERY
NEW GENERAL FUND DOLLARS THAT
WORK TO- COME TO BE. A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IN THE
PRIOR YEAR IS UP TO ABOUT
SEVENTY NINE POINT THREE
BILLION TOTAL CURRENT YEAR IS
NINETY TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION.
AND THE BUDGET YOUR TOTAL IS
NINETY THREE POINT SEVEN AND
THAT'S THE TOTAL FOR THE ENTIRE
GUARANTEED. NOT JUST BE OUR K.
TWELVE SHARE. THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES TO REMOVE WHAT WOULD
NOW BE A TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLAR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT'S OF
LITTLE PAYMENT WAS ESTIMATED TO
BE TWO POINT THREE BILLION. AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
THAT'S BE COOL TOO ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE PER FOR NOT ABOUT
EXACTLY 1405% OF TOTAL. GENERAL
FUND REVENUES- AND THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL PAYMENT ON TOP OF
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATION AND THIS WAS
PROPOSED. AFTER TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT TO BE APPLIED IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND IN
SEVERAL YEARS UNTIL AN AMOUNT
OF ABOUT TWO TWELVE POINT. FOUR
BILLION WAS REPEATED OVER
SEVERAL YEARS- AND WITH FACTORS
CHANGING SUCH THAT NOW. THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT PRECIPITATED
THAT COMMERCE. IN SOMETHING-
PROPOSING- THE OF ONE OF
PAYMENTS AS- PRETTY MUCH COULD.
RIVER WE HAVE WE ARE PROPOSING
TO REMOVE NOT ONLY ABOUT YOUR
PAYMENTS WHICH WAS OUR PROPOSED
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BUT
ALSO THE BUDGET YOUR PAYMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT
MORE IF FOLKS HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS- WHAT THE TEST ONE
AMOUNTS. FAR EXCEEDING THE
CALCULATED TEST TO AMOUNTS AT A
IN THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN OUR CAP
GAINS REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS
EXCEEDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTIONS THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESERVE DEPOSITS
ARE ALSO INCREASED FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO JUST
UNDER TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND-
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
RESPECTIVELY IN EACH OF THOSE
YEARS. AND SIMILAR TO OUR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FORECASTS
THAT AMOUNT OF A RESERVE
BALANCE AFTER THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. WOULD
TRIGGER THE SCHOOL DISTRICT-
SERVE CAPS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE PER STATUTE.
ADA AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
HAS CONTINUED TO DECLINE-
THOUGH WITH NOT MUCH OF A
PRACTICAL IMPACT ON THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING LEVEL SENSE INFLATION
AND ENROLLMENT CHANGES ARE ONLY
FACTORED INTO THE TEST TWO. AND
TEST THREE LEVELS AND AS I SAID
WE ARE STILL IN TEST ONCE. IN
EACH YEAR- WITH BROAD THE EIGHT
AT UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF FOR
PEOPLE FUNDING. ALMOST FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR PEOPLE AT
THIS POINT AT THE MAY REVISION-
THE MAYOR VISION MAKES SEVERAL
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS WITH
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FOUR
BILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND SIX BILLION. IN
ONGOING INVESTMENTS FOR K.
TWELVE STUDENTS DON'T PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHILE ALSO
PRIORITIZING RESOURCES. TO
THOSE THAT ARE IN COMMUNITIES
MOST JUST. REALLY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. WITH ALL OF NEW
OF A SPEND. AND THE COMPUTING
POWER THERE. WE ARE PROPOSING
TO ME. A BUDGET YEAR PAGE
DEFERRAL OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS ALSO ROUGHLY EQUAL TO THE-
R. NINETY EIGHT RESERVE DEPOSIT
I MENTIONED THAT IS HAPPENING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR- LASTLY. AS
MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD- DUE
TO A COMBINED. STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. OVERAGE
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL RECEIVE A TOTAL.
ESTIMATED CURRENTLY AT EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ABOVE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE. AS REQUIRED
PER THE CONSTITUTION CURRENTLY
PROPOSED ALLOCATION IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR ONCE THE FINAL OVERAGE
AMOUNT. IS KNOWN. YOU'LL HEAR
PLENTY MORE ABOUT THE SPECIFICS
OF THE DIFFERENT- HE TOLD
FUNDING PROPOSALS AT THE MAYOR
VISION OUT FOR ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES ON LEADER PANELS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON MY
PRESENTATION. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO THE L. A. O. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
GET ON WITH ALLEGE ANALYST
OFFICE I'LL BE GIVING YOU A FEW
SHORT HIGHLIGHTS AND ANALYSIS
OUR OFFICE PUBLISHED EARLIER
THIS WEEK. BACK IN JANUARY YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER US SAYING
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CONTAINED THE BIGGEST BET YOUR
INCREASE IN K. FOURTEEN
FUNDING. SINCE THE ADOPTION OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. AND
THIS MAY REVISION CONTINUES
RIGHT ON THAT SAME TRACK
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS BEFORE YOU
ALSO REPRESENT THE LARGEST
INCREASE IN FUNDING FROM
JANUARY TO MAY. I IN THE
HISTORY OF PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MENTION THOSE BIG
INCREASES THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AND THOSE INCREASES
REALLY ARE ABOUT 40% OF THE
INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
REVENUES. AS REQUIRED BY OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL FORMULAS. WE
THINK THOSE ESTIMATES OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES ENDING
HERE AND HERE REASONABLE WE CAN
GIVE YOU A GOOD STARTING POINT
FOR BUILDING YOUR BUDGET. I WE
ALSO THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT IS REASONABLE. THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT AS
FAR ABOVE THE CREEK AND THAT
DEMOCRATS WILL AS WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE HELLO THE CREEK AND
DEMOCRATS THE LAST YEAR AND- SO
THE RECOVERY THAT PAYMENT WAS
ATTENDED TO A CHEESE. HAS
HAPPENED. OF THE TOTAL INCREASE
IN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING OVER THE ENTIRE
NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO PERIOD. IS
FIFTEEN POINT FOUR BILLION. AS
FAR AS THE BASIC STRUCTURE OF
THIS BUDGET THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZES THAT HIGHER
GUARANTEE SETS ASIDE MONEY AS
REQUIRED IT TO MAKE THE HIGHER
PROPOSITION AND YET RESERVE
DEPOSIT- AND THEN ALLOCATES 89%
OF THE REMAINING INCREASE TO
SCHOOLS 11% COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE VERY SIMILAR TO THE STATE'S
ASKED PRACTICE ARE YOU HEARD
SEPARATELY ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROPOSALS- SO FOCUSING
JUST ON THE K. TWELVE- YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD A LITTLE
BIT OVER. I'M MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN POINT THREE BILLION
IN NEW I KICKOFF APOSTLES IN
JANUARY I JUST MAKE THE VISION
ADDS ANOTHER CALLED POINT SIX
BILLION IN NEW PROPOSALS ON TOP
OF THAT AMOUNT. SO TOTAL ON
THIS PACKAGE HAS ABOUT THIRTY
BILLION IN NEW K. TWELVE.
SPENDING PROPOSALS. I WON'T
COVER ANY OF THE DETAILS OF
THOSE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS YOU
YOU'LL GET INTO THOSE- IN LATER
PANELS. BUT JUST TO GIVE YOU A-
TAKE OUR OUR OF OVER TAKE- AT
THIS BIG OF. I THINK THIS WELL
WE THINK THERE ARE SOME KEY
STRENGTHS HERE SO JUST MAKE A
VISION HAS SOME Y. JOB LYNN
TATIAN IS FOR KEY LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES- ABOUT OTHERS MORE
FUNDING FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS- I'M MORE FUNDING FOR
STUDENT SUPPORT. A LARGE
DOCUMENTATION TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. ALL THINGS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN INTERESTED
IN IN THE PAST. THIS BUDGET
ALSO HAS A LARGE ONE TIME
QUESTION. OF THE TOTAL
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING THAT'S ATTRIBUTABLE TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SPECIFICALLY I NEARLY SEVEN
BILLION IS FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. AND THAT GIVES YOU
A LARGE ONE TIME QUESTION AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF WE
GUARANTEE WERE TO DROP NEXT
YEAR THE YEAR AFTER HAT. A
CHRISTIAN GIVES YOU A WAY TO
AVOID. CUTS TO ONGOING PROGRAMS
OR CREATING NEW DEFERRALS- ANTI
DOES NOT DROP. THE STATE CAN
USE THOSE FREED UP FUNDS AT
THAT TIME TO PROVIDE
AUGMENTATIONS THAT ADDRESS.
ISSUES THAT EMERGED AND NEW
CONCERNS AT THAT TIME. WE ALSO
THINK THIS MAY ADDITION HAS
SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN SOME AREAS
OVER THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET. WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
LATER ABOUT HOW WE THINK THE
TRANSITION PROPOSAL FOR
IMPLEMENTING UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. IS
BETTER THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD PUT FORWARD IN JANUARY WE
ALSO THINK THERE ARE SOME
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO HIS
PROPOSALS AROUND THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS GRANT PROGRAM. IN TERMS
OF- CONCERNS THAT WOULD
HIGHLIGHT- YOU'LL HEAR US I
THINK FLAG TO A LARGE PROPOSALS
THAT WE THINK ARE. AREN'T%
NECESSARY I SAW ONE OF THOSE IS
GOING TO BE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION FOR TARGETED
INTERVENTION AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER TWO BILLION FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY ACTIVITIES. WHAT IS
YOUR S. Y. L. USA IS THAT SALES
OUR TO PROVIDE A LOT OF FUNDING
FOR THOSE. AS IN SO. WE DON'T
THINK ANOTHER ROUND OF FUNDING
IS NEEDED AT THIS TIME. OUR
OTHER CONCERN IS THAT WE THINK
THIS BUDGET MISSES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD MORE-
SCHOOL BUDGET RESILIENCY SO
SPECIFICALLY LEAVING TWO POINT
SIX BILLION AGAIN DEFERRALS
REMAINING AND- NOT NOT
PROVIDING ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. I TRIED UNFUNDED
PENSION COSTS WE THINK THAT
ADDRESSING BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT STUDENTS BY
INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
DISTRICTS I CREATE THIS YEAR I
WITH ONE TIME FUNDING CAN BE
SUSTAINED OVER TIME. BUT ALSO
PREPARE DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
TO BETTER DEAL WITH THE NEXT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND SO WE
THINK SHIFTING FUNDING LOOK AT
MORE IN THAT DIRECTION. WITH
WOULD BE A VERY GOOD WAY TO-
IMPROVE UPON ON THE PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU. I SO WITH THAT-
COLLEAGUES AGAIN COVER A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES IN MORE DETAIL
WHAT IMPACT CAPITA ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NOW WILL MOVE ON TO ELOISE
GARDNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. OF. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ALLEN GARNER ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. WE
ARE PLEASED THAT THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES THE LARGEST
LEVEL FUNDING FOR EDUCATION AND
LARGEST K. TWELVE EDUCATION PER
PUPIL EXPENDITURE IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY. THE COMPANY
TEAM CONDEMNING HAS WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY GAPS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD. TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
OPPORTUNITY GAPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS RETURNED SAFELY
TO SCHOOL FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING AND TO MAKE SURE ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE A SAFE
AND SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND-
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXCEL. WE WERE JUST REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER THE
SAME COLOR FOR CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS AS FOR THE LCS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARTICULARLY
THE EXTENT THAT ADDITIONAL
REVENUES ARE IDENTIFIED. I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOMB. I'M
GOING TO ASK A QUESTION OF
FINANCE BUT IT'S MORE A BRIEF
STATEMENT TO AND THEN COMMENT
ON IT. IT AND IT JUST BASICALLY
WITH- OF. THE RECORD REVENUES-
THAT- ONE TIME WAS PROP NINETY
EIGHT WHY NOT PAY OFF THE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE IT SEEMS
THAT. THE INFERENCES SO WE'LL
HAVE MORE THAN THAT IN THE
EDUCATION OF RAINY DAY FUND.
AND IF THE ECONOMY TANKS OR
REVENUES GO DOWN WE'RE GOING TO
NEED THE MONEY IN THAT FUND TO
BRIDGE L. E. H. NOT TO PAY OFF
DEFERRALS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
PAID. OFF WHEN WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST ONE TIME MONEY IN THE
HISTORY OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
SO. WHY WAS THE CHOICE MADE TO
NOT PAY OFF THE DEFERRALS AND-
RELY IN THE FUTURE MAY BE ON
THE RAINY DAY FUND WHEN WE HAVE
THIS BIG AMOUNT OF MONEY.
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
AREA BERMAN FINANCE AGAIN. SO
THE WAY THAT WE I THOUGHT ABOUT
IT IS A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS
SO YOU MENTIONED THE- THE
INCREASE IN ONE TIME FUNDING
AND THAT'S TRUE BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT TO SOME EXTENT THAT'S-
EXACTLY WHY. THE DEFERRALS BE
MAINTAINING THE AMOUNT THAT IT
IS BECAUSE SHOULD WE MOVE TO A
FUTURE YEAR- WHICH GENERALLY
WILL ENSURE THE ECONOMY FARE
POORER THAN WE ARE CURRENTLY
EXPECTING AS YOU MENTION- THE
WAY THAT THE- RAINY DAY RESERVE
DEPOSITS WORK. IN THE FIRST
INITIAL TWO YEARS AFTER THEY
ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED DESERVES A
TRUCK MECHANISM. SO THOSE
APOSTLES ARE MADE BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT- THINGS CHANGE AND
IN THE ECONOMY AND THOSE ARE NO
LONGER NEEDED- THERE COULD BE.
AN IMMEDIATE JUST REDUCTION AND
ALL THAT SO IT'S ESSENTIALLY WE
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A ONE TIME
COST. IT FREES UP MONEY. IN THE
FUTURE BY IN A LIGHT COME OUT-
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT ECONOMIC
INDICATORS CHANGE SO MUCH THAT
THERE WAS ACTUALLY REQUIRED
WITHDRAWAL PER THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LANGUAGE. BUT
AGAIN THAT WOULD HELP US. AS
WELL AND I THINK FROM A LARGER
GLOBAL- ENTIRE BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE. WE REALLY LOOKED
AT OKAY BETWEEN THE MAKES OF
ONE TIME AND ONGOING FUNDING
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING. TO ALLOW
US TO- REALLY PRIMARY. ME
RESOURCES AS WE COULD TOWARDS
LIKE I SAID EARLIER THOSE
COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED OF IT
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC WHILE ALSO SHORING UP.
DISTRICT BUDGETS THROUGH A
PROVIDING A LARGER COLO FIVE
POINT 007% ON THE LC FIVE WHICH
IT IMPROVES FUNDING. FOR EVERY
DISTRICT EVEN THOSE WHO MAY NOT
RECEIVE. LARGE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS PERCENTAGE
AMOUNTS- DOT DOT I THINK WAS
DEFINITELY AN ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION. AS WELL AND I
THINK ON A CASH BASIS- THIS IS
JUST A JUNE TO JULY DEFERRAL
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE IN THIS
YEAR AND NEXT YEAR IS VERY
LIKELY WITH SO MUCH MONEY THAT
MEETING ELEAZAR RECEIVING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL
AS FROM US AT THE STATE- THAT
MANY. DISTRICTS ARE LIKELY TO
BE IN A RELATIVELY STRONG CASH
POSITION AND SO WE DON'T
FORESEE THIS AS- SOMETHING THAT
WOULD. REALLY BE. TO MUCH OF A
HARDSHIP FOR THEM IF AT ALL AND
WE ARE STILL MAINTAINING- THE
DEFERRAL EXEMPTION FOR THE
MONTH OF JUNE. FOR THOSE EARLY
AS THAT WOULD. DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE A CASH
HARDSHIP FOR THEM WHEN THE TIME
COMES FOR THAT TO FOR ALSO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS IN CONTACTS IS
WHAT LED US TO- MAINTAIN THAT
THAT AMOUNT OF THE FOR ALL THE
BUDGET YEAR. I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT I DO DISAGREE JUST BECAUSE
I WAS BUDGET CHAIR AT A TIME.
WHEN WE WERE UNDER WATER THE
WHOLE TIME AND BORROWED A AND
IT TOOK GOVERNOR BROWN FIGURING
OUT HOW TO GET US OUT OF DEBT.
OF BECAUSE SO MUCH HAD BEEN
ACCUMULATED AND JUST WHEN WE
HAVE THE MOST MONEY THAT WE'VE
HAD ABOVE PROJECTIONS IN MODERN
TIMES IT'S A TIME TO PAY OFF
DEBT. THEN SO- HE YOU KNOW WHAT
I. MORGES HEARING THIS WAY
MAKING NO DECISION BUT I WOULD
JUST ANNOUNCE OUR INTENT TO
HAVE IT AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO DO.
ARE THERE OTHER QUESTIONS ON
ITEM TO OUR- SACRAMENTO. PARDON
US SENATOR OCHO BOOK I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT ACTUALLY
SHOW THE SAME SENTIMENT THAT
YOU DO AS FAR AS PAYING OFF THE
DEFERRALS AND PAINT I JUST
FINANCIALLY AND EVEN FROM
EITHER SIDE HE'S ASSUMING THAT
THE DIFFERENT WOULD ONLY BE FOR
TOMB I FROM JOHN FROM JUNE TO
JULY FROM MONTH BUT SO THAT'S
INTEREST THAT'S BEING PAID AND-
JUST JUST FINANCIAL LITERACY
WOULD TELL YOU THAT. YOU ALWAYS
PAY YOUR DEBT FIRST. WE'RE NOT
GETTING INTO AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
FINANCIAL LITERACY. I'M JUST
TEASING I AM JUST DIESEL- I
PURCHASED YOUR COMMENTS AND I
THINK. OF FINANCES ABOUT BE
REALLY HAPPY TO BE RELEASED
FROM THE SIDE SO- WOULD THANK
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THAT WAS
SORT OF THE REVENUE SIDE AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FIVE
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE IN THE-
EXPENDITURE SIDE SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
WHICH IS THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND THE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INSTRUCTION. ARE WE HAVE- LENA
GRANT AND ERIN READ THE- FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE
HAVE MICHAEL R. FERRIS AND KEN
COUPON FROM THE L. A. O. AND
ELLIE GARNER AGAIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO
WE'LL BEGIN. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN GRANT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M GOING
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
FUNDING PROVISION. SO IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WE HAVEN'T ME
REVISED INCREASE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION. FOR A
CUMULATIVE YEAR OVER YEAR
INCREASE OF THREE POINT TWO
BILLION CONSUMER CALLED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE PROVIDED
ALMOST TWO BILLION IN POLICY
AFFECT THE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BRINGS THE- SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND CHARTER SCHOOL LCF
BACK. TO SIXTY FIVE POINT SIX
BILLION. AS FOR THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT WE PROVIDED A
COMPOUNDED COLA FOUR POINT OH
FIVE PERCENT. BUT THEN WE ALSO
ADDED 1% FOR THE L. C. AFFECTS
THE CIVICALLY WHICH CREATED AN
LC AFFECTS THE CIVIC COMPOUNDED
COLA FIVE POINT. SEVEN PERCENT.
THIS REFLECTS. ON AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL BASE GRANT
FUNDING. FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AT THE MAY REVISION
WOULD PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION
FOR A TOTAL YEAR OVER YEAR
INCREASE OF THIRTY NINE POINT
NINE MILLION. THAT'S TEN POINT
TWO MILLION AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THEN YOU JUST ON THE
REVISION INCREASE. OF TWENTY
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION- WE
PROVIDE COST LIVING IS. TO COME
OFFICE OF THE- AS THAT EXTRA 1%
FOR THE COMPOUNDED COLA FIVE
POINT 007% THIS BRINGS TOTAL
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION I'LL
SEE IF I FUNDING TO ONE POINT
ONE BILLION. I'M ON THE ALSO
CONCENTRATION FACTOR INCREASE
IT'S AN AGENDA AND MAY WE
REVISED ME INCLUDED INCREASE
THE LC FIVE CONCENTRATION GRANT
BY INCREASING THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT RATE FACTOR FROM 50% TO
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. WHICH
RESULTS IN THAT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
INCREASE. JUST AS THEY WERE
REMINDERS NOW RECEDED. GRANT AS
PART OF L. C. EXPENSE FUNDING
WHEN THE ENROLLMENT OF THEIR
UNDUPLICATED STUDENTS IS 55% OF
THE TOTAL ENROLLMENT OR
GREATER. THE PRIOR TO WHAT
WE'RE NOW INCLUDING AT THE
NEIGHBOR'S VISION A
CONCENTRATION GRANT WAS EQUAL
250% OF THE BASE GRANT
MULTIPLIED BY THE ELEAZER
PERCENTAGE OF U. P. P. ABOUT
55% THEY WERE SHIFTING THAT 50%
TO SIXTY FIVE. WHICH YIELDS AT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
WE ALSO.A TRAILER LANGUAGE THE
REQUIRE THAT ONLY. DEMONSTRATE
IN THEIR- CAPS. HOW THIS
INCREASE IN FUNDING WILL BE
USED TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES
THEREBY REDUCING ADULT TO
STUDENT RATIOS ON SCHOOL. AS
FAR AS INSTRUCTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR WE PROPOSE TO
RETURN TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR. TO THE MAXIMUM
EXTENT POSSIBLE AND OF COURSE
AS SAFELY AS POSSIBLE. HOWEVER
THE MAY REVISION DOES MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO THE EXISTING
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAMS- TO
GIVE UP AT LEAST THE OPTION TO
GENERATE STATE FUNDING BY
SERVING STUDENTS. OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM- IN RESPONSE TO
PARENT REQUESTS. EXACTLY IS
WILL PROVIDE NON CLASSROOM
BASED INSTRUCTION USING THE
EXIST EXISTING TRADITIONAL
INDEPENDENT STUDY MODEL. BUT
WILL ALSO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS LIKE PROVIDING
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY AND A DEDICATED
AND RIGOROUS CURRICULUM THE
ALSO BE REQUIRED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A FRAMEWORK OF TEAR
DURING GAUGE WENT TO THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATING AND
INSTRUCTION. WILL ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO TRACK AND RECORD
DAILY STUDENT PARTICIPATION IN
OUR AND INTERACTION WITH
STUDENTS WITH TEACHERS. FINALLY
ON THE EXPANDED LEARNING TIME
PROPOSAL REVISION PROVIDES ONE
BILLION IN PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOR EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME. ON THIS PROPOSAL
REFLECTS A FIVE YEAR PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT EXPANDED DAY FULL
YEAR INSTRUCTION AND ENRICHMENT
FOR ALL STUDENTS IN GRADES
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE SIX.
AN ALLEY IS THAT RECEIVED THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATIONS OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE NOT REPRESENTS
AROUND TWO MILLION STUDENTS. ON
WITH THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM BY THE YEAR TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX THE STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO NO COST
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
PROGRAMS. WHEN COMBINED WITH
REGULAR INSTRUCTIONAL TIME THIS
WOULDGIVE STUDENTS NINE HOURS
OF DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
ACADEMICS AND ENRICHMENT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY AND FOR SIX
WEEKS EACH SUMMER- ELEAZAR WILL
BE REQUIRED TO EXTEND
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME BUT THEY CAN
PROVIDE ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES
DURING THESE EXPANDED HOURS. SO
IN TERMS OF RECEIVING THESE
FUNDS- ALTHOUGH LEN WOULD
RECEIVE THE FUNDS AS A RESULT
OF BEING ELIGIBLE FOR THE LCF
CONCENTRATION GRANT THE
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM HAS
TO BE PROVIDED TO ALL STUDENTS
WHO WISH TO ATTEND SO. THEY
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM WOULD
SERVE ALL STUDENTS AND NOT JUST
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT
GENERATING STUDENTS AT THAT
SCHOOL. THAT'S ALREADY
MENTIONED- THE PROGRAM IS
FUNDED WITH ONE BILLION ONGOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND CHRIS TO FIVE
BILLION EXPORT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION BY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. OVER THIS
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD THE
SERVICES WOULD BE PHASED IN SO
THOSE ELLIE IT'S THE HIGHEST
PROPORTION OF STUDENTS. FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND FOSTER
USED WOULD BE PROVIDED THAT.
ACCESS TO THAT EXTENDED DAYS
LAST YEAR PROGRAMING FIRST.
FINALLY ONCE FULLY IMPLEMENTED-
DID MINISTRATION PROPOSES
INCORPORATING THESE FUNDS INTO
THE LCF CONCENTRATION GRANT
CALCULATION. AND I THINK WE'LL
HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL THIS- MY
COLLEAGUE- PRESENTS FOR
PORTION- I HEADED OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FINANCE FOLLOW UP ON
A SHARED TANK AND SHALL SPEAK
ON THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
FUNDING OR AN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. GREAT WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU IN
THAT GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS-
I WON'T ADD MY COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT THE PROPOSAL IN ISSUE FOUR
SO I WELL- YUP MY TIME AT A
TIME. OKAY. BUT THEN WE WILL
MOVE TO THE LA ON. MORNING MR
TRIMMER'S MICHAEL FERRIS WITH
THE ILLEGAL A FULL WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH PROVIDING THE
HIGHER COMPOUNDED COLA A FIVE
POINT 007% OVER THE ONE POINT
SEVEN PERCENT- STATUTORY COLA.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO PROVIDE
MORE I'M GOING FUNDING TO
SCHOOLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO CFS
VISIBLE WAY TO DO THAT AS A
BENEFITS ALL DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE SOME WITH LOOKS ABILITY.
THE PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT TO REDUCE
ADULT TO STUDENT RATIOS. WE
THINK THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
REASONABLE AND CONSISTENT WITH
THE INTENT OF THE CFS.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS WITH HIGHER
PROPORTIONS OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FOSTER YOUTH IN
ENGLISH LEARNERS. HELPS ENSURE
DISTRICTS CAN INCREASE FROM
CRUISE SERVICES THAT'S SUPPORT
STUDENT LEARNING AND WELL
BEING. THE PROPOSAL WOULD GIVE
CHECKS ABILITY FOR DISTRICTS
ASIDE HOW DOES THE BEST BEST
ADDRESS STUDENTS NEEDS- LESLIE
OR- SORRY- IN REGARDS TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INSTRUCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS BUT
WE JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO REVIEW THE
RECENTLY RE. RELEASED LANGUAGE
AROUND THE INDEPENDENT CITIES
PROGRAM BUT HAVE NO COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME ON THE PROPOSAL. I'LL
GO AHEAD AND DISCUSS OUR
COMMENTS ON THE EXPANDED
LEARNING GROUP OPPOSES SINCE
THAT WAS COVERED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE FINANCE- WE
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER THE TRADE OFFS
OF RESTRICTING THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR EXPANDED LEARNING-
S. ACCESS TO. SUMMER AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS CAN PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENGAGING
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL DAY. AND PROVIDED THOSE
REVISION FOR CHILDREN WITH
PARENTS WORKING TRADITIONAL
HOURS. ALTERNATIVELY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING FUNDING THROUGH A CFS
BUT GIVING DISTRICTS
FLEXIBILITY TO SPEND FUNDS ON
ACTIVITIES THEY THINK WILL BEST
ADDRESS OUR STUDENTS NEEDS
WHICH COULD INCLUDE. SUMMER AND
SCHOOL AT AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO TARGET FUNDING TO
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD
BENEFIT STUDENTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS SUCH AS
EXTENDING THE SCHOOL YEAR
PROVIDING INTENSIVE TUTORING OR
OTHER STUDENTS COURTS. ATTACK
INCLUDES OUR MARKS- I CALL THE
CAN COUPON AND I ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THEN WE'RE. GOING TO
MOVE ON TO- L. A. FOR THE- OF
PAGE. THANK YOU CHARLIE GARNER
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND WE
ARE THANKFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES TO MAKE EDUCATION A
TOP PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO FINALIZE
ANY OF THE PROPOSALS. AS LEGAL
WAY TO SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN
WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. I THINK THIS THOMAS START
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO EITHER OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE OF. OKAY CENTERMAN-
AND YOUR MARK. SO I GUESS- MY
FIRST QUESTION A COMMENT
ACTUALLY THIS IS MORE OF A
COMMENT IS JUST AROUND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR. AND I WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE- WHILE I BELIEVE THAT
IT IS SAFE TO RESUME PHYSICAL
INSTRUCTIONS AT THIS POINT
BARRING ANY SETS MAJOR
SETBACKS. AND WHILE I PLAN TO
SEND MY KIDS TO SCHOOL. AND I
WELL I THINK IT IS AN
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT THAT.
EVERY L. EA AND EVERY SCHOOL
ACROSS THE STATE OFFER PHYSICAL
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AS THE
DEFAULT. STARTING THIS FALL. I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION IS IMPORTANT
FOR OFFERING. VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION TO THOSE PARENTS
WHO MAY. NOT FEEL THAT THEY'RE
NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THE RISKS
OF SENDING THEIR KIDS BACK TO
PHYSICAL CLASSROOM AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT WHEN I TALKED TO I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT THIS BUT WHEN I
TALKED. A TRUSTED ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS THAT'S WHAT I'M
TOLD IS THAT WE JUST DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH DATA YET TO MAKE
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN
PROCLAMATIONS ABOUT SCHOOL RE
OPENINGS. MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT IT'S SAFE TO SEND OUR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL BUT THE BUT THE
CERTAINTY AROUND THAT IS NOT A
100% OR AT THAT LEVELS AT THIS
POINT. ARKANSAS I WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE THAT THERE ARE
PARENTS OUT THERE. THAT DAY FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEIR OWN
FULLER MEDICAL VULNERABILITIES
OR OR WHATNOT ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE SAYING THE KIDS
BACK TO PHYSICAL CLASSROOMS-
ANIES ARE NOT IRRATIONAL PEOPLE
THAT THE FALL YOU KNOW ON ONE
END OF THE RANGE OF BELIEFS OUT
THERE- BUT BUT I DON'T THINK
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE WE
SHOULD FORCE THOSE PARENTS TO
SEND THEIR KIDS BACK TO
PHYSICAL. CLASSROOMS AND SO I
WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT THIS HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS IMPORTANT
AND I WANT. TO ST MY STATE MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR IT- MY SAID.
I GUESS MY ACTUAL CLASS AND
I'LL PROBABLY **** ON THE NEXT
PANEL WELL- BUT EITHER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE
PERMIT. YOU KNOW WE SEEM TO BE
PUSHING A LOT OF MONEY TOWARDS
HELPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE HIGH CONCENTRATIONS OF-
LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNER AND
FOSTER CHILDREN AND I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IT
IS. HAVE YOU GUYS CALCULATED
WHAT THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF
ALL THIS IS BECAUSE AT SOME
POINT WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
AND WHEN I SEE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS STACKED ON
TOP OF PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY
EXIST TO TOE SPECIFICALLY
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO THESE THESE
PARTICULAR ALLEY AS- OR SCHOOLS
BOB I GUESS THAT MAKES ME
WONDER SIR WHAT WHAT'S THE
TOTAL AMOUNT THAT THAT THIS IS
A 75% CONCENTRATION SCHOOL
MIGHT GET THESE A V. A SCHOOL
THAT HAS FORTY NINE PERCENT-
AND HOW ARE WE LOOKING AT THE
BIG PICTURE ON THE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF OUR SCHOOLS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW
SCHOOLS THEY HAVE 40% 49% LOW
INCOME FOSTER KIDS ENGLISH
LEARNERS MANY OF THEM ARE
STRUGGLING WITH RESOURCES AS
WELL AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
THAT WE'RE ALLOCATING FUNDS
FAIRLY HERE. AS SO WE ARE GOING
TO CREATE A PERMANENT FINANCE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- WE
DO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL. 1%
BECAUSE THIS IS A- DIFFICULT
FOR. THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA SO THAT- EVEN THOUGH
THATGOES TO THE BASE GRANTS.
WHICH PROVIDE FUNDING FOR ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS- IT ALSO- PROVIDES AN
EXTRA BUMP TO THE CONCENTRATION
AND SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS. SO
THOSE THAT POPULATION THAT
REFER TO IF WE SPECIFICALLY
TARGET OUR POPULATION. AS WELL
AS OUR ONE POINT ONE BILLION.
DOLLAR CONCENTRATION GRANT
SPECIFIC INCREASE- WE INCREASE
THAT THRESHOLD FROM 5265%
WHICH- RESULTS NOT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION SO. WE TRY TO. TO
PROVIDE THIS EXTRA FUNDING
THROUGH EXISTING CHANNELS AND
NOT CREATE NEW PROGRAMMING
NECESSARILY. WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS DISTURBING THIS
POPULATION. YEAH I GUESS I
GUESS MAYBE I DIDN'T STATE MY
QUESTION CLEARLY SO I
APOLOGIZE. I GUESS I'M JUST
WONDERING YOU KNOW BETWEEN
THIS. CONCENTRATION FACTOR
INCREASED ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. YOU'VE GOT- I THINK IN
THE NEXT PANEL YOU'LL TALK
ABOUT- YES SANDY. LEARNING TIME
PROGRAM IN SOME OF YOUR OTHER-
EFFORTS AND AGAIN I WANT TO SAY
I'VE FOUGHT THE GOAL LIKE KNOW
WHAT WHEN WE- LOWER INCOMES.
AND LEARNERS THE DAY THEY DO
NEED EXTRA ATTENTION BUT IN THE
BIG PICTURE IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY THERE
AND MAYBE NOT AS MUCH AS WE
COULD BE TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND I GUESS I'M JUST ASKING ON
AGGREGATE LEVEL HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN LOOKING AT HOW MUCH
FUNDING. IN TOTAL YOU'RE YOU'RE
PUSHING TO- YOUR THESE HIGHER
CONCENTRATION SCHOOLS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE EXACT TERM IS
OBVIOUSLY JUST THE BASELINE.
THOSE CENTER MAN IF I COULD
JUMP IN HERE AND AT AND
APARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD- I
THINK I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION BETTER HERE THAN THAN
THE FIRST TIME SO- I WOULD
POINT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE LENA
MENTION TO. WE ESTIMATE THAT
THAT ADDITIONAL 1% COLA THEY
WERE PROPOSING AND I'LL SEE I
I'VE ONLY WHICH BENEFITS ALL
DISTRICTS EVEN THOSE THAT
WOULDN'T RECEIVE. BROWN'S
FUNDING AS WELL AS THOSE WHO DO
LIKE SHE MENTIONED- TO BE WORTH
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YOU'RE A LOAN- TO THE THAT'S
THE BOTTOM TO THE BASE FRANCE
OR EVERYONE WOULD FEEL THAT
THAT. ADDITIONAL INCREASE AS
WELL AS WE ESTIMATE ABOUT
ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS AMOUNT.
OUNCE FOR EVERYBODY THAT THAT
DOES RECEIVE. THOSE AND THEN I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WITH THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL- THERE IS
MORE THAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW ONGOING IN THE MONEY AND
I'LL SEE IF I FUNDING THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING OVER THE
CURRENT YEAR LEVELS AND IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK BACK ALL THE WAY
BACK I DON'T KNOW IT'S A LONG
TIME AGO BUT SO THE FIRST YEAR
BILL CFF IN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN-
THE STARTING POINT THERE WAS
ABOUT FORTY BILLION DOLLARS SO
WITH THE MAY REVISION NOW.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AROUND
TWENTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
NEW FUNDING FOR LC ABOUT NOW
YES SOME OF THAT A GOOD PORTION
OF IT HAS GONE OUT- VIA THE
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANTS BUT THE BOWL THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THAT HAS BEEN THE
OF THE BASE FRANCE AS WELL SO
EVERYONE HAS BENEFITED ALL ALL
DISTRICTS ALL STUDENTS- AND
THEN I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
WITH THE UPCOMING NINETEEN TEN
DEMOCRATS AND ALL THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE DISTRICTS HAS
RECEIVED. THOSE BILLIONS UPON
BILLIONS WERE DOLED OUT LARGELY
BASED ON TITLE ONE- TITLE ONE
ENTITLEMENTS AND SO YOU HAVE.
DISTRICTS THAT DON'T EVEN.
CONSTANT UNDER I'LL SEE IF
AFTER THAT MAY HAVE HAD LARGE
SHARES ABOUT THE SOLAR AS- AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO DO GET
CONCENTRATE GRANT- FINDING. AND
THEN. ALSO A SEVERAL OF OUR ONE
TIME PROPOSALS GO OUT BASED ON-
ON LEDS PROPORTION OF OVERALL
LCS FAST AND SO THAT WOULD ALSO
APPLY TO THOSE WHO. WHETHER
THEY HAVE CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE FROM
US YOU FELT. OR NOT YEAH- AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED ABOUT
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME WHICH WE
WILL TALK ABOUT LATER ON IS
TIED TO AN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO INCREASE- FOR
THOSE ELEAZAR RECEIVE THE
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY TO
INCREASE NON INSTRUCTIONAL TIME
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL
AS THE CONCENTRATION BROWN
FUNDING INCREASE OF ONE POINT
ONE BILLION. IS SPECIFICALLY TO
BE TIED TO DEMONSTRATING HOW AN
ELLIOTT RECEIVED THOSE THAT
INCREASE WOULD BE REDUCING
ADULT STUDENT RATIOS ON THEIR
CAMPUSES IN THOSE OTHER ELLIE
AS THAT WOULD RECEIVE THAT
MONEY WOULDN'T HAVE NOT SEEN
REQUIREMENTS SO- IN IN ARGUE
THAT'S WHERE THAT. KIND OF
EQUITY BILITY OF IT COMES IN
AND WE ALL SUPPORT EQUITY AND
WANT TO SEE BETTER EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES I GUESS MY QUESTION
JUST OR MAYBE IT'S MORE A
STATEMENT AT THIS POINT. IS
THAT IF I'VE GOT NUMBER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAT HAVE LIKE 49%
45% CONCENTRATIONS. AND THEY
GET ZERO AND YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT THE 1% CALL IT WAS A FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE. IN YOUR PROVIDING AS
I IF I'M READING THIS CORRECTLY
ONE POINT ONE BILLION AN
ONGOING FROM NINETY FUNDING.
OFFERED THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH THE 65% CONCENTRATION-
WHICH YOU KNOW IT LEAVES A LOT
OF SCHOOLS OUT WITH YOU KNOW A
LOT LESS AND I GUESS. YOU KNOW
I DON'T YOU GUYS LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS MORE CLOSELY THAN I
EVER WILL BUT- YOU KNOW WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS IS ONE POINT ONE
BILLION FOR THOSE WITH 65%
PLUS. BUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE 45% OR 55% CONCENTRATIONS
ONLY GET TACKLE INCREASE AND
YOU COULD CERTAINLY CHANGE UP
THE PRIORITIES HERE TO JUST
INCREASE THE BASE FUNDING
LITTLE BIT MORE. AND MAYBE
PROVIDE LESS MONEY SO I GUESS
I'M REALLY JUST LOOKING FOR THE
JUSTIFICATION HOW MUCH OF THIS
IS NEEDED AS WORK THINKING
ABOUT THE BROADER BIG PICTURE
BUT- I DON'T WANT TO TAKE UP
TOO MUCH TIME SO. JUST LEAVE IT
WITH THAT STATEMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- SENATOR
AND IT AND DO TALKED ABOUT TWO
TOP. ARM TO TALK. IT N. HE DID
A GOOD. BUT LET ME JUST S.
FINANCE MAYBE ASTOR
CONCENTRATION GRANT QUESTION A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY. WHICH
IS AWESOME- WHY IS ADDITIONAL
STAFFING TIED TO THE
CONSERVATION I MEAN THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT DIVISIONAL
STAFF IS NEEDED WHY NOT CREATE
A SEPARATE PROGRAM AND TARGET
STAFF TO SPECIFIC SCHOOLS OR
FOR SPECIFIC NEEDS. SO CHANGE
YOUR QUESTION CENTER WHERE I
THINK OUR THINKING WITH OUR
PROPOSAL IS THAT- THE L. CAP IS
ALREADY PART OF THE LCS PFAFF
IN THE LOCAL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS MAKING SURE
THE ELEAZAR ARE REALLY TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY NEEDS THE NEEDS OF
THEIR STUDENTS. AND SOME BY
FOLDING THIS FUNDING INTO THE
ALSO HAVE A CONCENTRATION GRANT
IN KEY INCREASE FOR THOSE
SCHOOLS WITH THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF SAID HIGH NEED
STUDENTS- WE'RE TYING IT INTO
THAT EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE ALL CAP NOT CREATING SO YET
ANOTHER- SILO TO PROGRAM
OUTSIDE OF THE L. C. F. ASK.
THAT NOW DISTRICTS ARE HAVING
TO COMPLY WITH WE FELT THAT
ROLLING IT INTO THE LCF I'VE
REALLY MAKES IT MOST CONSISTENT
WITH OF COURSE THE IMAGES OF
LOCAL CONTROL ETCETERA- SO THAT
DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE THIS
FUNDING. ARE ABLE TO- REALLY
BETTER ALIGNED WITH ALL THEIR
OLD ARCHING L. PER. AND HAVE A
LIVE SOME ELSE OF THAT WELL. I
APPRECIATE THAT IT THE SAME
TIME. IT MEANS THAT SCHOOLS
THAT MIGHT HAVE A NEED- OUTSIDE
OF IT BECAUSE IT IS JUST
TARGETED TO THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE AND I GET TO DECIDE
WHAT WAS BEST A BUT I THINK
THAT'S- THAT'S THE PROBLEM AND
MAYBE WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. I THINK
THE THIS ITEM R. A. I WANT TO
ASK THE AND ALSO A LITTLE TOO
TO WHAT SENATOR MEN SAID ABOUT
SCHOOL RE OPENING BECAUSE- AND-
JUST AS A COMMENT BECAUSE I
READ THE EXCHANGE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I THOUGHT IT WAS A
FALSE CHOICE. A QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER- WHAT IS PROPOSED WOULD
ALLOW 90% OF STUDENTS NOT TO
COME BACK IN SOME DISTRICT AND
I THINK THAT'S THE WORST FEARS.
OF SOME PEOPLE THAT WANT
SCHOOLS TO COME BACK IN PERSON
AND YET THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY SUGGESTING
ANYWHERE THAT 90% OF THE
STUDENTS IN ANY DISTRICT WON'T
COME BACK. I THINK IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE. THAT THERE
ARE SOME PLACES AND THERE'S A
STORY I THINK AT THIS MORNING'S
LA TIMES IT'S IN THE NEWS THIS
MORNING ABOUT PICO RIVERA. AND
THE LOS THEY HAD THEIR- MUCH
COVETED AND THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE AREN'T READY. SOME TO
COME BACK PERSONALLY DOING IT
BECAUSE OF THAT. AND WE SHOULD
NOT DRIVE THOSE PARENTS OUT OF
THE SYSTEM AND WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO FUND THE LOSS OF
ENROLLMENT OTHER SCHOOLS AND SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK WHAT THE DETAILS STILL
HAVE TO BE TALKED ABOUT. THE
NOTION THAT THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT PEOPLE COME
BACK BUT THE OPTION. IF PEOPLE
COME BACK AND NOT IN PERSON IS
STILL REQUIREMENT FOR
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND IT'S
STILL MONITORED AND YOU CAN
STILL DEAL WITH ADA. IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE DRIVING PEOPLE ON
THE MARGINS OUT OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM AFTER THIS
HAPPENED SO. WHILE THERE MIGHT
BE SOME THE DETAILS TO STILL
TALK ABOUT I THINK THE GENERAL
DIRECTION OF THE BUDGET. TO
ALLOW FOR INDEPENDENT STUDIES
AND THAT IS A GOOD ONE AND SO
WE SHOULD JUST WORK THAT OUT.
AND THEN A MORE GLOBAL COMMENT
BECAUSE EVERYTHING FITS
TOGETHER HERE. WE HAVE ONE
ITEM. ABOUT SPECIAL OF PROGRAMS
THAT'S THAT STILL TO COME. AND.
SOME OF THEM ARE TO BE STOOD UP.
IN WHO THE MONEY ON THE RECALL
REPORTING ON DISTRICTS THERE'S
A QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
CAN GET THE MOP. BOB BARR IN
TIME WHEN THERE'S A ONE TIME
MONEY AND WE WANT TO SPEND IT-
BEFORE. THE REQUIREMENTS
PARTICULAR ON THE FEDERAL MONEY
THAT THAT MIGHT LIMIT ITS
ABILITY TO BE SPENT OVERTIME.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH THAT'S A
CONVERSATION TO HAVE ABOUT
THEIR IT RAISES THE ISSUES
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THE BUDGET FOR. R.
ELIA IS FOR EXAMPLE. EITHER A
FURTHER PAYMENT TOWARD PENSION
COSTS. FOR A PAYMENT TOWARD
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS WHICH
UNIVERSALLY PEOPLE FEEL LIGHT
UP- CARD ISSUED FUNDING THE
BUDGET AND IF WE ARE HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING MONEY OUT THE
DOOR IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO PUT
SOME OF IT TOWARD THOSE TWO
THINGS IN THIS. AND WHILE THAT
MIGHT BE BETTER SET IN OTHER
ITEMS THESE ALL FIT TOGETHER
AND I THOUGHT I WOULD JUST
RACES HERE AND JUST SAY THAT
THAT IN WHATEVER CONVERSATION
WE HAVE ABOUT THIS AND THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
EXPENDITURE SIDE. WE JUST
BELIEVE THOSE NEED TO BE ON THE
TABLE AS WELL IN THE
DISCUSSIONS OF ALL THE GIVES
AND TAKES THE THAT ARE ABOUT TO
COME AND SO I WOULD SUGGEST
MAKE THOSE COMMENTS BECAUSE-
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS ARE
GOING TO BE REAL CONVERSATIONS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS
WE HEAR THESE TO WEIGH THE
ISSUES. ON THE TABLE SO THAT
NOBODY'S SURPRISED ABOUT WHERE
THE DISCUSSION GOES ARM ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ADDITIONALLY BEFORE WE LEAVE
THIS ITEM. THEN LET ME THANK
OUR PANELISTS- SHADED IN
LIMITED KNOWLEDGE. ONCE AGAIN
THAT COMING FROM THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION WHERE IF YOU
OVER USED ACRONYMS SHE WENT TO
PRISON- THAT LAST DISCUSSION
WAS DIFFICULT FOR SOME PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT NOT BE TOTALLY
SCHOOLED. IN THE SUBJECT AND-
HE YOU KNOW WE ARE THIS IS ALSO
PUBLIC EDUCATION SO I APOLOGIZE
WILL TRY TO BRING PEOPLE ALONG
ISSUE FOR A STUDENT SUPPORT
PROPOSALS AND- OUR PANELISTS.
THE FIRST FOUR NINE SUSPECTS
ARM NOT ALL BE SPEAKING BUT
WILL LET THEM DO IT WIENER
GRANT PAULA FINASTRA TANG AGAIN
LIST MY AND AMBER ALEXANDER.
AGAIN MICHAEL R. FERRIS FROM
THE ALEJO'S OFFICE AN ALLEY
GARDNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S- ALTERNATE OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND LET
YOU DECIDE. WHO'S SPEAKING IN
WHAT ORDER ON THE SIDE WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I MEMBERS
BEING A GREAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I AROUND YOU SLEEP WENT
THROUGH THE EXTENT OF LEARNING
TIME PROPOSAL IN THE LAST ISSUE
I JUST WAS SO EXCITED ABOUT IT
SO- I'M GONNA HOLD MY COMMENTS
FOR NOW SO I WILL REPEAT MYSELF
AND- ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS
FOR ME UP OFF THE GROUND- BUT
I'M AND I HANDED OFF TO POLICY
WHAT IS YOUR TANK MY COLLEAGUE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND SHOULD SPEAK ON THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY FUNDING- OR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. GRADE TEN
WE WILL NOTE YOUR A. PERSONAL
EXCITEMENT FOR THE RECORD. AND
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT. THANK YOU
RENOWNED GOOD MORNING CAL
MEMBERS POLICY CAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FRIEND
MINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT WE
WILL NEED TO BLOCK TRAFFIC THAT
WOULD ARE SAFER FULL TIME
RETURN IN THE FALL. SO THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES TWO BILLION
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY ACTIVITIES SUPPORT
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. THIS
FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
SUPPLEMENT THE TWO BILLION
INCLUDED AN EBT FACT I WAS USED
TO COVER COSTS OF REOPENING IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. AND ALLOW IT
TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING SCHOOLS
AND OUR EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
FAMILIES FEEL SAFE WHAT KIND OF
THE CAMPUS. ALLOWABLE USES
INCLUDE VACCINE AT THE
INITIATIVE AND HAS ACTIVITIES
AND IMPROVE. VENTILATION THANK.
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT GO BACK
HEARING THINK AGAIN SECOND THE
MAN RELATED CLOSING GAP. YEAH
THAT AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD IS
INCLUDE HIS BILL. ONE TIME
FEDERAL. AND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME POP OF THE
NINETY GENERAL. THE SCHOOL.
PROVIDE TARGETED RESEARCH HAS
BEEN IN. BUT YOU DIDN'T
DISAPPOINT AND BY CALL THAT NAY
PAN. THE FUNDS ARE ALSO TO. THE
PARKWAY SIX BILLION PROVIDE TO
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY FOR BACK OF.
BUT WE ARE CREEK PARK AND WE
HAS AND I. THAT ADDRESS HOW
MANY INCLUDING PER HIGH
TUTORING AND HAVE. TO READ YOU.
FINALLY IT'S BEEN A REVISION AT
THE- EXPAND UPON THE
COMMUNITIES WHAT ARE PROGRAM
THAT WAS INCLUDED THAT GOVERNOR
BUDGET BY INCREASING THE IMPACT
TO JUST OVER THREE BILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL.
GIVEN THE BY THE BOOK AND-
FEDERAL TO ARE INCLUDED IN
TRAILER LANGUAGE TO PRIORITIZE
BY FOR NEW CAMINO SCHOOL. AND
BUILT OUT TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT AFTER
AND OTHER YOU MAY BE INTERESTED
IN APPLYING FUNDING. SECOND
KRIZAN MARC MY COLLEAGUES AND I
FROM AT THE OF FINE- ARE HAPPY
AS ANY. THANK YOU MUCH A. N.
THE OTHER TO FIND PEOPLE ARE
HERE TO FOR QUITE. BACHARACH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO A MICHAEL
FERRIS OF THE ALEJO'S. THANK
YOU MISTER TRIMMERS MICHAELA
FERRIS AGAIN WHAT THE ELIO- A
SURE COMMENTS ON THE EXTENT
EXTENT ALERTING REBEL CALLS ON
THE PREVIOUS PANEL SO ALL HOLD
OFF ON SHARING THOSE AGAIN
INTERESTING TIME. FOR THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS BACK OPPOSED
PROPOSAL WE THINK THAT THE
CHANGES MADE TO. IMPROVE UPON
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL. WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
MODIFICATIONS TO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PARTICULARLY. THE
CHANGES IN THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE FUNDING IS
PRIORITIZE FOR CREATING
PROGRAMS THE EXPANSION OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
GRANTEES. AND A CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS THAT. ARE SET FOR
THE SUPPORT SCHOOLS WILL
RECEIVE. OF THE MAY RIVER
PROPOSES. INCREASE IN FUNDING
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING SMALLER
MODEL FUNDING INITIALLY. BY
ADDING FUNDING IN FUTURE YEARS
IF DEMAND IS HIGH. OF LESLIE WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE TWO
PROPOSALS FOR TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS AND HEALTHY AND
SAFETY ACTIVITIES. SCHOOLS HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED MORE THAN
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS DURING LOS AND IMPROVE
HEALTH AND SAFETY. MORE THAN
TWENTY BILLION FOUR BILLION O
THAT IS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND MORE THAN SIX
BILLION IS FROM THE STATE. OF
THESE FUNDS DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY PROVIDED CAN BE USED TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THIS IS SPECIFIC
ACTIVITIES OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS. INCLUDING
TARGETED INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS
HIGH DOSE TOURING AND
ACTIVITIES TO REOPEN SCHOOLS.
ACTIVITIES WITH NO CLEAR
JUSTIFICATION AS WHEN WE'VE
SPOKEN TO DISTRICTS THEY'VE
INDICATED THAT THEY HAVE NOT
SPENT ALL OF THE ONE TIME FUNDS
IT PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED PRAISE
ACTIVITIES. AND ALTHOUGH
DISTRICTS FACE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
OPENING SCHOOLS AND ADDRESSING
LEARNING LOSS. IS CHALLENGES
DID NOT APPEAR TO STEM FROM THE
LACK OF FUNDING. A SECOND CLSE
MY REMARKS ACCESS OR ANY
QUESTIONS APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
COMMENTS THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ELLIE GARDNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. HM
NUMBER IS ALLIE GARNER ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
IN THE MAY REVISION ALIGNED
WITH THE SHARED GOALS OF THE S.
P. I. ENSURING EQUITABLE
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS AND
PRACTICING ON STUDENTS HAD
HARNESSED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
OUR TOLL LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE AFTER
SCHOOL AND SUMMER LEARNING
PROGRAMS SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS THAT PROVIDE WRAP
AROUND SERVICES AND ENSURING
OUR STUDENTS CAN SAFELY RETURN
TO THE CLASSROOM ARE ALL
CRITICAL PIECES OF THIS PUZZLE
WE WOULD NOTE THOUGH FOR THE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION HEALTH AND
SAFETY GRANT. THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS APPROPRIATED.
DOT NET. AS OPERATED ON DOES
NOT IN THE STATE'S SCHOOL
INSTEAD AT THE IS THE OBJECT
YOU NEEDED ELIGIBLE LOCAL I. T.
EACH NEEDS DOES COUNTY ALL OF
EDUCATION OR CLASSROOM BASED
DIRECT KIND OF CHARTER SCHOOL
CD WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT SOME
AMOUNT. SHOULD LIKELY BE
APPROPRIATED FOR STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS CD NOTES THAT MUCH OF
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
TARGET ON GETTING AND KEEPING
SCHOOLS OPEN INCLUDING THE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION PORTION
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX IT WAS PASSED
EARLIER THIS YEAR. BUT AGAIN
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE STATE
SPECIAL SCHOOLS AS SUCH THE CD
REQUEST OF THE LEGISLATURE. LET
LEGISLATURE KEEP STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS IN MIND WHEN PROPOSALS.
ABOUT ALL OF THESE GRANTS SO
THAT WE ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS. IN THE STATE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SAFELY RETURN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. WELL THESE
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE SECTION IS
DESERVING OF FULL PANEL IN
ANOTHER ITSELF I WILL AND I
REMARKS THERE TO KEEP THINGS
BRIEF. I HAVE WITH ME MULTIPLE
CITY STAFF WHO ARE EXPERTS IN
EACH OF THESE AREAS TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M GONNA
LEAD WITH TWO QUESTIONS HERE.
IN ONE IS FOR OF FINANCE AND
IT'S IS IT FOLLOWS UP ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S COMMENT
ON THE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND TARGETED INTERVENTION
GRANTS ARE GIVEN THAT- LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE
RECEIVING THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE FUNDS FOR THE SAME
PURPOSES ON HOW DID THE
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINED THAT
MORE FUNDS WERE NEEDED FOR THIS
PURPOSE. AIRPARK CHECKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
BELIEVE I CAN NOT THAT THAT TWO
BILLION IN THE PROPOSAL FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY SUPPLEMENT
WITH YOUR BILLION AND EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX PACKAGE FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY EFFORT. THE FUNDING
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHTY
THANKS OR THE BAGGAGE COVER
COSTS EVERY OPENING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR I THANK THEM FOR
THEY'RE FINDING REMAINING COST
TO BE CARRIED OVER INTO THE
NEXT YEAR. THE TWO BILLION IN
THE MAYOR REVIVED BY HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN COMPETITIVE FOCUS ON
HELPING SCHOOLS CONTINUE AFRICA
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION BY
PROVIDING DEDICATED FUNDS
AVAILABLE OVER TWO YEARS. I
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT THERE
WILL BE AN INCREASED COST
AROUND CLEANING AND HAVE
FINALLY SENT ANOTHER HOW THE
BABY NEEDS AT WORK WITH BACK IN
THE FALL AND CRACKED. WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO. THAT
UNLIKELY THAT THERE BE A
VACCINE AVAILABLE TOO MANY. AND
FALL AND MANY TACKLE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THEIR CHOI BACK
SCHOOL. WE WANTED TO PROVIDE
GLOBAL THE REFI. NEEDED TO BE
STATE. ERICA CAL STATE STOP AND
GO. SPENDING A- TO. AND A TWO
BILLION COULD BE USED FOR
SCHOOL TO HOLD. AND I OF AND
THAT THE VARIETY PURPOSES
INCLUDING BACK BEING CLINIC
LOOKING BACK TO COMFORTABLE.
AND ALSO PROTECT. ABOUT WHEN.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO KNOW
IS THAT BOTH OF THAT IN A
PROPOSAL THAT I WITH THE- IS
THAT AS MAJORITY OF I DON'T.
FIND THAT HAVE BEEN COMING WENT
OUT BASED ON PROPORTION OF
TITLE ALEX. THE COULD NOT GO
OUT TO ALL WE GAVE. THE FUNDING
FOR PROPOSAL. DOC LEN ON ALTHEA
THOUSAND TITLE MEANT. FOR THE
INTENTION OF THAT THE PEOPLE.
AND THAT PEOPLE HOUSES AND LONG
THAT I BINDING AND TARGET IN A-
BROWN WILL BE SPREAD OUT MORE.
ACROSS WITH. ALL OUT. ACTUALLY
NEED TO GO FOR THAT SO I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION. AND THEN MY OTHER
QUESTION IS ON THE EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME. AND I JUST HAVE
TO SAY BUREAUCRATICALLY WHEN
YOU READ THIS. R. IT HAS A CUT
OFF OF A 55% ENROLLMENT FOR LOW
INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH THAT WOULDN'T GET.
ANY FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME FOR
STUDENTS. AND IT JUST SEEMS
CRAZY TO ME THAT WE WOULD
FUNDED PROGRAM ANELLI A WITH
55% AND THEN IF SOMEBODY HAD
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. OF YOUR
WITH REGARD TO LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND FOSTER USE
WOULD SAY OH YOU DON'T GET
FUNDED. ISN'T THERE SOME BETTER
WAY THAT THERE'S NOT SUCH AN
ARBITRARY CUT OFF I MEAN
SCREENING OUT SOMEBODY THAT AS
54% IN THAT CATEGORY JUST
DOESN'T SEEM PRODUCTIVE. AND I
WOULD DIRECT THAT TO THE L. A.
ALL. RAIMES I I'M SORRY MATTE
FOR FINANCE BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT
DE LA- WHO'S JUST SCRAMBLING
THERE WILL WILL HAVE A CONTACT.
IF I COULD HAVE MY UNCLE A-
BRAWL AS TO THE QUESTION SURE.
BRAWL WITH THE MATERIAL IF IT
DIDN'T TO THE SUPERBOWL I THINK
MILLION. HAS INDICATED THAT THE
INTENT IS TO PHASE THE PROGRAM
OVER SEVERAL YEARS. I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
WHICH WITH BEIJING THE PROGRAM
MORE TIME HOW I WOULD LOOK I
WOULD AFFECT WHAT WHAT WOULD.
YOU SAY FIVE YEARS FROM NOW. IN
TERMS OF OUR GENERAL- OFF ON
THE ON THE PROGRAM WE BIG.
MONEY FROM ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OVERALL BIG PICTURE BIGGER
THINGS- ON THE THIRD DISTRICTS
OF HIRING COULD BE WE'VE GOT
WAS REASONABLE ARE BY. DID YOUR
POINT REGARDING THE ARE THE
POTENTIAL CLINICAL IS ALREADY
VERY GOOD SORT OF ARBITRAGE
PROFITS I THINK I WOULD NOT
CHOOSE. IN THESE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE CONCENTRATION GRANT
PARK ROAD NOTE THAT THE
CONGRESS BRACKETS DID NOT
CREATE THAT ARBITRARY CUTOFF.
IF YOU ARE A FIFTY FIVE OR 56%
R. O. U. B. V. SCHOOL DISTRICT
YOU GET CONCENTRATION FUNDING
BUT IT'S VERY VERY SMALL OVER
TIME THAT WILL MAKE IT BIGGER
SO WE DON'T HAVE THE SME
PASSWORD ARBITRATE COOP IN THE
CORNER ON THE LEFT ARM- WE DO
OUR- YOUR POINTS ARE NOT
CREATING SOME- LINE WHERE. I.
ONE POINT. DO YOU CAN YOU GET
THIS FUNNY IT OUT OF YOU
WOULDN'T. DEGREE FROM JOHNSON
WE DO KNOW THERE ARE TWO LARGE
PIECES CAL OUR AROUND. WILL
FINANCE YOU HAVE A.
WE'LL WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME NOT REPRESENTS
ROUGHLY TWO MILLION STUDENT
CHILDREN HAD FULL
IMPLEMENTATION SO WE DON'T SEE
THIS AS- REALLY. YOU KNOW I'M
VERY SELECTIVE KIND OF SMALL
POPULATION OF CONCENTRATION
GREAT GENERATING SCHOOLS- THAT
POPULATION IS QUITE LARGE IN
THE STATE AND- WE WERE JUST
SPEAKING TO- IMPROVE THE TARGET
THAT SPECIFIC POPULATION BUT
REALLY. THAT FUNDING IS SPREAD
OUT TO ALL STUDENTS AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT THAT GENERATE THAT
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING.
AND IF AND THIS IS JESSICA
HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF
I MAY ADD ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO- I THINK
TOO THAT THAT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF ROLLING
THIS PROPOSAL OUT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT A FIVE YEAR TIMELINE
I THINK IT TO THE EXTENT WE
HAD- UNLIMITED FUNDS- AND
LIMITED TIME- WE WOULD. HAVE TO
BE TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING THIS
AT THESE FUNDS AND WORK THIS
REQUIREMENT TO ALL SCHOOLS. AND
THIS WAS THE CHUNK THAT WE FELT
LIKE WE CAN BREAK OFF- AND THIS
WAS THE POPULATION THAT WE
WANTED TO START WITH IN TERMS
OF ROLLING THIS OUT I WOULD
NOTE THAT OUR CURRENT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM ASUS IS MEANS
TESTED PROGRAM AS WELL- AND
PROVIDES FUNDS FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND SUMMER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING- FOR ELEAZAR THE
HIGHEST PROPORTIONS OF FREE
REDUCED PRICE MEALS. SO REALLY
BUILDING OFF OF THAT- AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE STARTING NOW
AND WHERE WE'RE SEEING
OURSELVES GO AND SORT OF THIS
NEXT FIVE YEAR TIME HORIZON
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE LOOKING AT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT ONCE.
NOTE THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE PUT
INTO PLACE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO EXPAND TO COVER ALL ON
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
ALL ELEAZAR BUT THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE STARTING FROM- AND THIS
IS THAT THIS IS THE PROPOSAL
WE'RE TRYING TO KIND OF. START
THIS PROCESS OF ROLLING. IT OUT
AND FOCUSING ON THESE KIDS
FIRST. AND LET ME JUST MAKE A
COMMON BECAUSE- OUR- I THINK
YOU YOUR QUEST. ARE ADVOCATE
FOR WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING BUT
STILL DON'T TOTALLY ADDRESSED
THE QUESTION BECAUSE- IT'S-
IT'S WELL WE WILL LIMITED MONEY
AND WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
ALL THE PEOPLE. THAT ARE
ENTIRELY IN THE SCHOOL BUT IF
YOU HAVE 54% OF THESE
CHALLENGING. OUR POPULATIONS
YOU DON'T GET IN THE DOOR AND
THERE MIGHT BE A BETTER WAY. TO
ACTUALLY TARGET. THAT
POPULATION BY DISTRICT ABOVE A
CERTAIN LEVEL THAT'S LOWER- ARE
AND THINK ABOUT IT DIFFERENTLY
SO. I JUST THINK- OF THAT YOU
GAVE US AN OPENING FOR SAYING
IT'S BEING PHASED IN OVER FIVE
YEARS AND I JUST THINK THAT
NEED TO BE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT REALLY WORKS OTHERS NOT
SUCH AN- ARBITRARY CUTOFF. FOR
SOMEBODY THAT HAS A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN THAT
CATEGORY. LET ME ASK- DO ANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. BY SENATOR MEN. YEAH
I JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON ON
GERMAN THERE'S COMMON- YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE GOT A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WROTE A HIGH CLASS
AREA. AND YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL
WE HAVE IS A SENATOR LOWER
DESCRIBED THE PROBLEM OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT MIGHT HAVE FORTY
FIVE OR FIFTY FOUR PERCENT- LOW
INCOME ENGLISH LEARNER AND
FOSTER USE. AND AS YOU POINT
OUT YOUR YOUR PROPOSAL. LIKE
CREATES WINNERS AND LOSERS
WHICH IS IF YOU'RE A 55% YOU
GET THIS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
YOU GET A LOT OF MONEY FOR
THAT- AND THAT BENEFITS ALL THE
STUDENTS NOT JUST THE ONES THAT
ARE LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND FOSTER USE. OURS IF YOU'RE
THAT 54% YOU GET NOTHING AND
THAT APPLIES FOR BOTH LOW
INCOME STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR.
THOSE THAT MIGHT BE WORKING
CLASS AND IN PARTICULAR THE
HIGH COST- LIKE MINE WE MAY NOT
ALWAYS QUALIFY BUT THEIR P.
THERE'S A REAL NEED FOR AFTER
SCHOOL ENRICHMENT. FROM A LOT
OF HOUSEHOLDS THAT CAN AFFORD
IT. AND I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
PROPOSAL CREATES REAL WINNERS
AND LOSERS- IT'S NOT WELL
TAILORED AT. THIS POINT IS
SENATE EARLIER DESCRIBED. I A-
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SUPPORT EQUITY
I THINK THAT EQUITY HAS TO BE
TARGETED ON WAYS TO ACTUALLY TO- THE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED HELP WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT OUR OUR- SCHOOLS ARE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ACROSS THE
BOARD ARE ARE. YOU NOT HAVING
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO MEET
THEIR BASELINE REQUIREMENTS.
AND WE KNOW THERE A LOT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT EVEN WITH
A 1% INCREASE ARE ARE GONNA BE
STRUGGLING. ON BOTH THIS FALL
AND GOING FORWARD. AND SO I
GUESS I JUST ECHO TERMINAL.
COMMENTS HERE IN AND JUST ASK
YOU KNOW WHEN WE TAKE A STEP
BACK. THIS IS A ZERO SUM GAME
AND WE HAVE FINITE RESOURCES
AND WE DON'T HAVE THIS I THINK
YOU MENTIONED ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. UNLIMITED
RESOURCES TO FUND EVERYTHING.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHY MAKE THE
CHOICES WERE MAKING AND I DO
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK
THAT. YOU KNOW MORE FUNDING FOR
THE LCF FORMULA. ALL FOUR BASS
LINE IS SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE EMPHASIZED A BIT
MORE AS WELL- BECAUSE I WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL SCHOOLS
FOR. THOSE THAT HAVE 50% OR
EVEN LESS THAN THAT. ALSO GET
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO.
DEVELOP A GOOD IN SCHOOL. AND
AFTER SCHOOL TYPES OF PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NEEDED. HANK THANK
YOU A CENTRAL JOB OF. THE
QUESTION I AGREE WITH THAT
SENTIMENT INCIDENT ALERTS
QUESTION I DO HAVE A QUESTION
HOW DO YOU FOLKS HOW DID THE
FIFTY FIVE INCH MARC COME INTO
PLAY- HOW DID HOW WAS THAT
DETERMINED. END OF WHO IS THAT
IS THAT DEPARTMENT OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PROBLEMS
CAN. EVERYBODY'S TAKEN A STEP
BACKWARD AND NOBODY HAS TAKEN A
STEP FORWARD. THE NONE OF US
DOWN BUT THIS CENTER THERE-
AREA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO I
WAS NOT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DURING THE INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHEN THE
55% THRESHOLD FOR SUPPLEMENTAL-
FOR EXCUSE ME FOR-
CONCENTRATION GRANTS WAS
ESTABLISHED- BUT I IMAGINE IT
WAS A LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSION
AT THE TIME AS TO WHY THAT CUT
OFF WAS. DECIDED I WOULD REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT ALL
DISTRICTS DO RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING ON TOP OF
THE BASE GRANT AMOUNT WHICH IS
EQUAL 220% OF THE BASE GRANT
MULTIPLIED BY ALL OF THEIR ADA-
IN IN EVERY ALLEY A AND THAT'S
REGARDLESS OF- THAT 55%
THRESHOLD OR NOT- AND THEN WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR- MORE RECENT
PROPOSAL AT THE MAY REVISION
AND IT BEING TIED TO THAT 55%
THRESHOLD CONCENTRATION
GROUNDS- THAT'S REALLY LIKE I
SAID. IN MY PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
MEANT TO PROVIDE SOME SYNERGY
BETWEEN THIS NEW PROPOSAL AND
SOMETHING EXISTING THAT HOUSE
LIKE I SAID THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE AWARENESS LIKE THE LCS
FAST SO THAT WAS REALLY
THINKING UP UNFORTUNATELY AS TO
THE- HISTORICAL QUESTION- I
PERSONALLY CANNOT SPEAK VERY
WITH MUCH EXPERTISE TO THAT
BUT- PERHAPS PERHAPS SOMEONE
ELSE CAN READ FROM THE ILIO-
BUT YEAH THAT'S- THAT'S THE
ANSWER FROM HERE. I THINK WE'LL
TAKE THAT ARE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS CENTER NO
QUESTIONS AS THE COMMON JUST
THAT I AGREE I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE AN INCREASE IN THE BASE
FINDING- FOR ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
I THINK THAT WOULD BE OF GREAT
BENEFIT TO ALL. OF OUR ELEAZAR.
THANK YOU. PLAN ON JUST NOTE
THAT. WOMEN ARE COMMON AND NOT
THAT'S TO BE A SORT OF TAKING
ACCOUNT BY OUR IN COMMERCE- ARE
AS WE MOVE ON THE BUDGET. FOR
ME THANK THE PANELISTS OF FOR
THAT ITEM. AND SOME OF YOU ARE
LEAVING AFTER BEING HERE FOR
MULTIPLE ITEMS SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE TEACHER
WORKFORCE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WITH KIM WHY HE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DR MERRY SANDY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. AND
MICHELLE PERALTA ALSO FROM THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND SOMEBODY'S
GONNA SAY CDC AND I'M AND I
THINK IT'S THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION SO
LET ME JUST SAY AGAIN. TEACHER
CREDENTIALING- ELLIE GARNER
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MY NAME IS LEE FROM
THE L. A. O.'S OFFICE AND WE'LL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KIMBERLY LEAHY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
I WILL BE PROVIDING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION.
AND THE STATE EDUCATOR
PREPARATION AND TRAINING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
FOR SEVERAL PROGRAMS THAT WERE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THESE
INCLUDE AN INCREASE OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO EXPAND
THE CAPACITY OF THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION ONE TIME DOLLARS EXCUSE
ME ONE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE EDUCATOR AFFECTED MISSED
LOCK GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT IN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANTS ARE
MADE REVISION PROPOSAL ALSO
BUILDS UPON EXISTING APPROACHES
ME PRE EXISTING PROGRAMS
INCLUDING. AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AVAILABLE OVER
FIVE YEARS IN TO SUPPORT AND
EXPAND THE EXISTING TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY SCHOOL LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY THAT DELIVERS HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROMOTES
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS
AND PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
LEADERS. TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
AVAILABLE OVER FIVE YEARS TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL GRANTS OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TEACHERS
AND EARNED A NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFICATION AND AGREED TO
TEACH IN A HIGH PRIORITY SCHOOL
FOR AT LEAST FIVE YEARS. AND
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND IS INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
TEACHERS AND PARA PROFESSIONAL
STATEWIDE IN STRATEGIES FOR
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION. AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE LEARNING EXPERIENCES.
ALIGNED TO THE COMPUTER SCIENCE
CONTENT STANDARDS ST EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANT.
ALSO INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION EXTENSION TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING IN ONE
POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO A SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COMPUTER SCIENCE
COORDINATOR. FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS IN SEVERAL NEW
PROGRAMS AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS
TO ESTABLISH A COMPUTER SIENCE
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION
INCENTIVE GRANTS AND SUPPORT
SIX THOUSAND TEACHERS IN
COMPLETING THE COURSEWORK
NECESSARY. TO EARN A
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION TO
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE THIS
AMOUNTS TO UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
PARTICIPATING TEACHER USED FOR
COSTS OF COURSE WORK BOOKS FEES
AND TUITION S. APPLICABLES. IT
JUST THE MARY BETH FROM TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO WAIVE THE CREDENTIAL FEE FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN TRYING TO K.
TWELVE EDUCATOR WORK FORCE IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO NONE OF THESE FUNDS WILL
BE. PROVIDED FOR RENEWAL
CREDENTIALS ONLY NEW
CREDENTIALS AS AN INCENTIVE TO
MOVE MORE INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
TEACHING WORKFORCE. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES FORTY
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO CREATE A NEW
ROADMAP TO THE PRE K. TWELVE
EDUCATIONAL EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
AT THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THIS PROGRAM IS
AIMED AT IMPLEMENTING A LONG
TERM COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT AND COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY. THAT WILL FOCUS ON
RECRUITING AND DEVELOPING A
DIVERSE AND TALENTED
EDUCATIONAL WORKFORCE I LIKE
THE VALUE OF WORKING IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SECTOR ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS MOVING INTO THE PRE
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATED
WORKFORCE FIGHT AND IDENTIFYING
AND SHARING RESOURCES. SUCH AS
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS AND THE
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS TWO TEACHING
AS PART OF THE ROADMAP PROGRAM
SIXTY FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. IS PROVIDED
TO THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND OPERATION OF
UP TO EIGHT STATEWIDE REGIONAL
EDUCATOR RECRUITMENT AND
SUPPORT CENTERS THESE CENTERS
WILL SUPPORT EDUCATED
CANDIDATES AT ALL POINTS ALONG
THE PROCESS FROM EXPRESSING
INTEREST IN BECOMING AN
EDUCATOR. TO THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THEIR FIRST YEAR
OF. TEACHING INSTRUCTION.
FINALLY S. S. FINALLY RELATED
TO PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TEN
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE THE
CONTRACT WITH ONE OR MORE
AFFILIATED TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING DISTRICT
IN READING INSTRUCTION FOR ALL
STUDENTS WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
DIVERSE LEARNERS INCLUDING
LEARNER EARLY LEARNERS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS STUDENTS WITH
PILLS DISABILITIES AND STUDENTS
WITH DYSLEXIA AND TOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORWARD
A PACKAGE OF APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT EDUCATOR
INITIATIVES I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND NOW I'D
LIKE TO HAND IT OFF TO MARRY
STOCKTON MERRY SANDY AT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. DR SANDY WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD MORNING SURE LAYERED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
WE ALTHOUGH CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE CHRONIC SHORTAGES IN
THE TEACHING WORKFORCE THE
SITUATION WILL BE EXACERBATED
BY EXPECTED RECORD RETIREMENTS
THIS YEAR. RECRUITING
DEVELOPING AND RETAINING THE
NUMBER OF CREEK TEARING THROUGH
GRADE TWELVE TEACHERS AND OTHER
EDUCATORS WING REQUIRES A MULTI
FACETED MULTI YEAR EFFORT IN
THE MAIN REVISED PROVIDES
HISTORIC AND SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
HE TO OUR EFFORTS WILL BE
ENSURING THAT OUR EDUCATOR
PREPARATION INSTITUTIONS OF THE
CAPACITY TO ENROLL AND PREPARED
THIS WORKFORCE ME REVISED
PROPOSALS FOR BROWN'S IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT TOWARD THAT
END. WE NEED TO AT LEAST DOUBLE
THE NUMBER SB K. THROUGH TWELVE
OUR TEACHERS COMING INTO THE
PROFESSION OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS TO ADDRESS THESE JORDANS.
THE PROPOSED FUNDING STRATEGIES
AND THEY RE PRICE WILL ALLOW US
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARD THIS GOAL AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK. YOU VERY MUCH AND-
I THINK YOU'RE YOUR OTHER IS
HERE FOR QUESTIONS ANOTHER
CORRECT LET'S GO LET'S GO TO
ELLIE GARDNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU CHAIR. WE GARNER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AS I
NOTICED IT NOTED IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS IN THE NEIGHBORING
VISION ALIGNED WITH THE
SHACKLES OF THE SS PI
SUPPORTING IN DIVERSIFYING OUR
TEACHER WORKFORCE IS A CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER. ANY OF THE TEACHER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN OUR
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE CTC.
WITH THE CVS ACCORDING OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR TEACHERS AND
OUR EDUCATED WORK FORCE. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT TEACHERS ARE
BIGGEST ASSET IN CLOSING THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP AND WE NEED TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST. SPECIFICALLY MALE
TEACHERS OF COLOR AND TEACHERS
IN THE FIELDS OF SCIENCE MATH
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION. EARLY
RESEARCH SAYS SHOWS THAT
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
HAVE MORE THAN DOUBLED THE
PROPORTION OF TEACHERS. TEACHER
CANDIDATES OF COLOR WHEN
COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. TEACHERS PREPARED
RESIDENCY PROGRAM STATE OR OUR
ROUTINES AT THEIR SCHOOLS AND
TEACHING PROFESSIONS AT HIGHER
RATE PARTICULARLY IN SCHOOLS
AND HISTORICALLY HIGH TEACHER
TURNOVER RATE. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE QUICKLY THOUGH. THAT SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
OUTLINED DO NOT INCLUDE. ARE
CALLED PRE EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND DON'T INCLUDE RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS AT CD
I WOULD NOTE THAT- BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM IS PRE EXISTING
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS AND-
ADDITION A THIRTY ARE REQUIRED
TO DO SOME OF THIS WORK AND WE
DON'T SEE THAT. ADDED IN THE
MAY REVISE AND LIKES AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE I'LL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS THERE AND CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
WILL MOVE TO EMILY FROM THE
TELESALES OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS ANY LEAVE ALEJO
SERVICE MORNING WE HAVE THREE
OVER ARCHING POINTS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ON THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROPOSALS AND I WILL BE KEEPING
HIS BRIEF. FIRST WE THINK THAT
CAPACITY FOR NEW OR EXPANDED
PROGRAMS WILL LIKELY BE LIMITED
IMMEDIATELY POST PANDEMIC MAY
REVISION PROVIDES ROSES
NUMEROUS NEW AND EXPANDED
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
WHICH REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT GIVEN THE
LIKELIHOOD OF BURNOUT AND
FATIGUE AMONG MANY SCHOOL STAFF
SCHOOLS MAY BE UNABLE TO
IMPLEMENT OR TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE INITIATIVES IMMEDIATELY.
RESPONSE THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER FOCUSING ON A
FEW IMMEDIATE PRIORITIES TO
HELP STUDENTS AND STAFF RECOVER
FROM THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
AND EITHER REJECTING PROPOSALS
OR EXTENDING SPENDING DEADLINES
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS. SECOND WE
NOTE THAT THE- TRAINING
PROPOSAL'S OVERLAP WITH THE
USES FOR FEDERAL FUNDING
SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBLE FUNDS FROM
RECENT FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGES
WHICH CAN BE USED FOR VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT- THE
LEGISLATURE ME JUST WANNA
CONSIDER HOW. THE EDUCATOR
TRAINING PROPOSALS COULD BEST
COMPLEMENT AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING. LASTLY WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
REQUIRING CLEAR DELIVERABLES
AND EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
EDUCATOR TRAINING PROPOSALS
SEVERAL NAY REVISION PROPOSALS
INCLUDE FEW DETAILS ON THE
DELIVERABLES AND EXPECTED
ACTIVITIES TO FIND IT. SOME
PROPOSALS DO NOT SPECIFY THE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES TO BE
SUPPORTED WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AS IS THE CASE WENT
BACK EARLY MATH INITIATIVE AND
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SCHOOL
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY. OR LACK
ROUTINE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AS IS THE
CASE WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANTS INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY'S FOR LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY. WE THINK OPPOSE IT
ESTABLISHING A CLEAR SET OF
DELIVERABLES AND EXPECTATIONS
FOR EACH PROPOSAL WOULD HELP
ENSURE SPEND OUR- FUNDS ARE
SPENT AS INTENDED AND ACHIEVE
THE DESIRED OUTCOMES. WITH THAT
HAPPY TO COMPLETE MY TESTIMONY
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
PERFECT. TIME FOR SELF. THANK
YOU VERY. I HAVE A OF. BILL A
MAJOR. SAID TO WAS GONNA COME
UP SOME POINT ANYWAY. ADD ON TO
THE L. A. O.'S COMMENT THAT WAS
JUST MADE BECAUSE- THERE'S A
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT THIS
BUDGET THROUGHOUT WHAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED IN THIS HEARING.
THEIR NUMBER OF NEW PROGRAMS OR
EXPANDED PROGRAMS AND THE
QUESTION IS. HOW ARE WE GOING
TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A
VALUATION TO KNOW THAT THE
MONEY IS LAID OUT. IS ACTUALLY
BEING EXPANDED AS INTENT AND SO
I THINK THAT. THAT AS WE MOVE
TO CLOSE THE BUDGET WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF. THE IN THE OUR OUR
BUDGET HEARINGS ARE DE FACTO
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND WE CAN'T
HAVE OVERSIGHT UNLESS WE KNOW
FOR A FACT. THAT WHAT IS
SUGGESTED IS ACTUALLY BEING
DONE AND SO- I JUST MAKE THAT
IS A GLOBAL COMMENT. LET ME ASK
A QUESTION OF THE- OF DOCTOR
MERRY SANDY. FROM THE
CREDENTIALING COMMISSION. WHEN
YOU TEST. AT OUR HEARING IN.
FEBRUARY I BELIEVE IT WAS.
THERE WAS NO DATA YET ON
RETIREMENTS- OF TEACHERS DURING
THE PANDEMIC ALL THE STATISTICS
THE LATEST STATISTICS WERE
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC AND I DID
NOTE THAT IN YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY YOU SAID EXPECTED
RETIREMENTS IMPLYING TO ME THAT
THAT THAT DATA STILL DOESN'T
EXIST WHILE THERE WAS SOME
DATA. ON THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS
THAT HAD APPLIED FOR
RETIREMENTS- HE IS THERE ANY
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING YET ABOUT
LOSS OF TEACHERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND COMPARED TO THE
NORMAL RATE OF ATTRITION. SO I
DON'T HAVE ADDITIONAL REPORTS
FROM CAL STIRS UP ON THIS AND
HAVE NOT HEARD ANY KIND OF
EXTENSIVE UPDATE ON THIS I KNOW
THAT- I BELIEVE AT THE TIME OF
OUR PRIOR HEARING WE WERE
EXPECTING WE'D HEARD IN
EXPECTATION OF ABOUT SIXTEEN.
PERCENT OF RETIREMENT RATE THIS
YEAR BUT I DON'T HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION STEEP
PERCENT OF TOTAL TEACHERS. OF
THE WORKING TEACHING FORCE
THAT'S MONUMENTAL S. AND WHAT
IS THE ANNUAL RETIREMENT
AVERAGE FOR THE PRECEDING YEARS
PREVIOUS TO THIS YEAR AND THIS
I DO NOT KNOW OKAY SO WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO COMPARED TO BUT IT
IT JUST ON ITS FACE SEEMS LIKE
THAT'S INCREDIBLY LARGE AND I
THINK THAT IT'S JUST A
STATEMENT THAT. WE WANT TO KNOW
THIS EVEN IF WE'RE NOT
SCHEDULING A HEARING WE WOULD
LIKE YOU TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
INDIVIDUALLY AND THE STAFF WHEN
THIS DATA IS NO SERVER WE ARE
CLEAR AND CAN FACTORED INTO OUR
WORK. AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD WOULD BE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND I
WAS GOING TO ASK BEFORE THE
TESTIMONY DO THE L. E. H. HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO STAND UP AND
EXECUTE ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE PROPOSED IN THE SECTION AND
THEN- THE- A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SAID THEY ARE. OF FUNDED IN A
WAY TO DEAL WITH THEIR ROLE IN
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS SO LET
ME ASK FINANCE- HOW DO YOU
ASSESS WHETHER THE L. A. AS
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO STAND UP
AND EXECUTE THESE PROGRAMS AND
DO YOU HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO
THE- THE CD THE THESE COMMENTS
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO.
PARTICIPATE I'M YES KIMBERLY
LEAHY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. BUT BASED ON DATA
FROM THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING WE BELIEVE THAT-
THEIR EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
CERTAINLY- ABSORB ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY FACTOR THERE IS THERE
HAS BEEN AN UNMET NEED FOR
TEACHER RESIDENCIES.
RESIDENCIES THE CREATURE
CREDENTIALING- PROGRAM THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN WELL
RECEIVED BY ELLIE AS AND THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE MORE
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS. AND
WE'VE ALSO HEARD- WHITE A NEED
FOR- ADDITIONAL COMPUTER
SCIENCE INSTRUCTION IN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND SO SEVERAL OF
OUR INVESTMENTS- TEND TO
ADDRESS THE NEED TO. PREPARE
MORE TEACHERS TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE- COMPUTER SCIENCE
INSTRUCTION- WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE PREPARED TO- ASSIST
THEIR TEACHERS AND- AND
OBTAINING THE AUTHORIZATIONS
AND THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS TO PROVIDE
THAT INSTRUCTION- AND THEN AS
FAR AS- THE- DEPARTMENT-
NEEDING MORE RESOURCES TO.
MANAGE OVERSIGHT OF SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS. THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED WITHIN THE ON THE
LEDGE OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THESE PROGRAMS. OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR- SOME
MONITORING AND REPORTING AT
CERTAIN POINTS THROUGHOUT THE
PROGRAMS ARE AT THE END OF THE
PROGRAM'S. AND WE'VE ALSO- HAVE
A COUPLE HAVE CALLED A COUPLE
OF EXTENSIVE EVALUATIONS ON
CERTAIN PROGRAMS. AND WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU MORE YOUR STAFF IN
YOUR OFFICE WITH DETAIL ON THAT
IF YOU WOULD LIKE- BUT WE'VE
TRIED TO. KEEP THE- RISK OF
THOSE READ WE- AS MINIMAL. FOR
THE DEPART S. HA. SO THIS THEY
COULD EASILY ABSORB WITHIN
RESOURCE AND YOU NEED AND THAT
AND SOME OF THE LANGUAGE THAT
THEY ARE TO DO THEIR BEST TO
MAXIMIZE AND OPTIMIZE- THEY'RE
REPORTING- ABILITY WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES. I'M GOING
TO IN A SECOND OUR CALL ON C.
D. E. WHO HAS THEIR HAND UP.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY YOU SPOKE
TO THE NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM AND
I DO NOT QUESTION THE NEED OF I
WAS ASKING ABOUT THE ABILITY
TO. TO STAND THESE UP AND DOTHEM AND SO- I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT FOR ME BUT NOW THAT WILL
STILL WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT I
THINK THAT'S- MAYBE I
MISUNDERSTOOD BUT IT SEEMS
DIFFERENT THAN THE NEED FOR THE
PROGRAM OF THE BUILDING TO
STAND IT UP SOMEONE YOU
RECOGNIZE OF. THE. WE GARNER
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU CHAIR
GARNER BEHALF OF STATES IN.
PUBLICANS TWENTY THURMOND. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT IT'S NOT JUST
RECORDING AND MONITORING THIS
IS REQUIRED OF CDP FOR MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS WHETHER PRE
EXISTING OR OR NOT IT'S RUNNING
THIS PROGRAMS AND SO WHAT WE
WOULD NOW IS THAT THERE'S A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
ON INVESTMENT FOR NEW
NATIONALLY BOARD CERTIFIED
TEACHERS THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE ANY
PROVISION FOR RESOURCES FOR CDT
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM. IS
ALSO- OR THE NEW COMPUTER
SCIENCE OR READING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DID DID. THAT ARE PART OF THE
KNEE REVISION WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS MINIMAL REPORTING
AND MONITORING BUT STANDING UP
THESE PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
CURRENT STRUCTURE. IS NOT
SUFFICIENT AND SO WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED SOME SUPPORT. ON
THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN STATE
OFFICE AS WELL AS A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE. TO
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PROMISED. MAY I MAY I
CORRECT THE RECORD. ON IN TERMS
OF PROJECTED RETIREMENTS FORUM
SURE. SO ONCE RAFTER JUDY
WOODRUFF TIES TO DO THAT BEFORE
THE END OF THE NEWS BROADCAST
AS WELL. OKAY WELL I'M IN GOOD
COMPANY THEN- IT'S NOT SIXTEEN
PERCENT- THE PROJECTED NUMBERS-
THAT WE'VE SEEN ROM CAL STIRS
ARE AT AROUND SIXTEEN THOUSAND.
AND IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY YEAR- THE RETIREMENT WAS
AT AROUND TWELVE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX THE PRIOR
YEAR IT WAS THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PLUS. ALL THE LAST TIME WE SAW
AS MANY AS SIXTEEN THOUSAND
TEACHERS RETIRE WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE TEN THAT'S THE-
TIME TO THE GREAT RECESSION.
YEAH GREAT RECESSION CARRILLO
SEN THANK YOU SAID TO THEM YOU
KNOW WE WILL PUT AWAY OUR BLOOD
PRESSURE PILLS. SO WITH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CORRECTION- ME
GO- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATORS
ANYTHING. WE DO NOT HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND I DIDN'T GO DEEPER
INTO THIS BECAUSE I THOUGHT
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WOULD BUT
LET ME NOPE NOPE NOPE NOPE JEFF
LET ME JUST SAY THAT- THE- THAT
I WENT INTO IT AND I THINK WE
WILL WANT TO LOOK INTO THE
FINER POINTS OF SOME OF THE
SAYS. AS WE NEGOTIATE THURMAN
AND GO THROUGH THE BUDGET
STANDOFF I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S- PRESENTATION. OF
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A
MAJOR ISSUE- ISSUE SIX THE
EARLY EDUCATION. AND WE HAVE
JESSICA HOLMES- WITH. EMMA ALSO
HAVE- EARNED LISTED AGAIN FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SARAH
CORTEZ AND ALSO HAVE CAN COUPON
LISTED FROM THE AUDIO AND SERRA
NEVER MORGAN FROM THE- A CDP SO
LET'S TAKE THEM IN THAT ORDER
AND- WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
WILL START WITH JESSICA HOLMES.
MORNING MR CHERRY MEMBERS
JESSICA HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE MAYOR THIS INCLUDES
A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. TO EXPAND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
BEYOND THE THREE MONTHS AS A
FOUR YEAR OLD WHO CAN CURRENTLY
ACCESS THE PROGRAM. ON TO A
FULL TWELVE MONTHS OF FOUR YEAR
OLDS TO ALLOW ALL STUDENTS TO
ACCESS THE PROGRAM. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
WHICH BEGAN IN THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- SCHOOL YEAR AND
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED OVER A
SERIES OF THREE YEARS- IN WITH
FULL IMPLEMENTATION IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE-
ANTICIPATED AND TO BE GENERATED
BY THE EXPANSION OF THIS
PROGRAM. IS APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE GROWING TO TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION ON GOING.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO REVENGE THE
GUARANTEED. TO BRING TO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE TO BRING NON
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. INTO
THESE THE STATE SCHOOLS FUNDING
WHICH IS PROP NINETY EIGHT I'M
JUST TRYING TO BREAK IT DOWN A
LITTLE BIT FOR FOLKS WHO MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND. WHAT WHAT THAT
MEANS BUT BRINGING BRINGING NON
IDENTIFIED SCHOOL DOLLARS INTO
THE SCHOOL FUNDING SYSTEM- IN
ADDITION TO THIS PROPOSAL WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO. DECREASE
THE CURRENT RATIOS THE ADULT TO
STUDENT RATIOS IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS AT
SPECIFICALLY. BY FUNDING AN
ADDITIONAL ON EITHER CLASSIFIED
OR CERTIFICATED STAFF PERSON
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS. I'M AT A COST OF
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE GROWING
TO SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND
THIS ADDITIONAL STAFF PERSON
WILL ALLOW RATIOS TO LOOK A
LITTLE MORE SIMILAR IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AS
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE LOOK IN
OTHER. ON FOUR YEAR OLD
PRESCHOOL OR PREKINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS- IN ADDITION WE SEE
THIS A PROPOSAL AS PAIRING WITH
THE EXTENT OF LEARNING PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE A- FULL DAY OF CARE-
FOR WORKING FAMILIES- IN THOSE
OF THOSE CONCENTRATION GRANT
DISTRICTS WHERE THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROPOSAL WOULD BE.
UNFUNDED I WILL I WILL LEAVE MY
PRESENTATION THERE JUST TO KEEP
IT SHORT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
ARE I ASSUME MR RADIUS HERE TO-
FOR QUESTIONS ARE. NO THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE SERVER
CORTEZ FROM THE DALLAS OFFICE.
MORNING SIR CORTEZ LA- I'M
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS AND MY COLLEAGUE CAN
COMBINE IS GOING TO BE MAKING
THE COMMENTS FOR OUR OFFICE-
FOR. THEM MISTER COUPON WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I THINK
YOU MISSED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SO I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
AS- YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER IS
BACK IN JANUARY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS. ALSO HAD A
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
EXPANSION OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- THERE WAS SOME
ONE TIME INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM. BUT IT
WASN'T THERE TO US WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO
ACHIEVE OVER THE LONG RUN- SO I
THINK THIS MAY REVISION
IMPROVES UPON THAT BY PROVIDING
A SPECIFIC- GO ALL AN
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE. AND
SOME TRANSITION FUNDING. THAT'S
ALIGNED WITH THE PROPOSAL- JUST
IN TERMS OF THE FIRST- THIS
SIDE OF THIS PROPOSAL. SO THIS
THIS DECISION TO BE THE
GUARANTEE ESSENTIALLY THAT IS A
PROPOSAL TO RE CALIBRATE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FORMULAS OVER TIME IS THAT THEY
GENERATE MORE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAN THEY WOULD OTHERWISE I
WITH THE IDEA THAT THAT THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL COVER-
THE EVENTUAL TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND IN THINKING ABOUT THE
DECISION FOR A BENCHING THAT
REALLY JUST COMES DOWN TO YOUR-
OVERALL BUDGET PRIORITIES. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
INCREASE A GUARANTEE LIKE THAT
IS ALLOWABLE IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE DON'T THINK
IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED.
WHAT IT REALLY MEANS IS THAT
OVER TIME THE STATE WOULD BE
ABLE TO SPEND MORE ON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PROGRAMS. AND LESS ON NON
PROGRAMS. THAT DIFFERS FROM AND
THE- PROPOSED STAFFING
REDUCTION PROPOSAL- THAT WOULD
BE PAID FOR WITH WITH AN
EXISTING GROWTH IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. ARE THERE ARE STILL
SOME IMPORTANT DETAILS TO BE
WORKED OUT I THINK THE MOST
THEM I. WHAT'S THE POINT ONE IS
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT
CURRENTLY SERVES A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF FOUR YEAR OLDS AND SO
IT WILL BE IMPORTANT WE THINK
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ENGAGE
IN THAT PROGRAM AND- IN SHAPING
THE FUTURE OF WHAT THE SCOPE OF
THAT PROGRAM IS AND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE MOVING FORWARD- BUT
ALL IN ALL THIS IS I THINK-
MUCH MORE FLESHED OUT. I THINK
A PROPOSAL THE MONEY'S ON
JANUARY. AND WITH THAT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
WILL MOVE TO A CERTAIN LEVEL
MORGAN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THEIR NOVEL MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO RETIREMENT THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO
SEE HAS STARK INVESTMENTS IN
EARLY EDUCATION PROPOSED TO ME
REVISED. DECADES OF RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATE THAT HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING EXPERIENCE. CAN
HAVE LONG LASTING IMPACTS ON
BOTH SHORT TERM OUTCOMES AND
LONG TERM OUTCOMES. THESE HIGH
QUALITY LEARNING EXPERIENCES IN
THE PRESCHOOL YEARS ARE
POSSIBLE INVEST SCHOOL BASED
AND COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS
THAT NED TO BE ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE FOR HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAM STANDARDS. RECENT
RESEARCH OUT OF BOSTON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOUND THAT THEIR SCHOOL
BASED PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THE
STATE COLLEGE ATTENDANCE SAT
TEST TAKING AND HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES WHILE ALSO
DECREASING. JUVENILE
INCARCERATION. WE HOPE THAT THE
PER A STARK INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSITIONAL. KINDERGARTEN
FORTY K. WELL LET CALIFORNIA
SERVICE EACH OF THE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLD
CHILDREN IN THE STATE. WAS
FAMILIES WISH TO ACCESS A HIGH
QUALITY IN FREE KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM AND ALLOW CALIFORNIA
DISTURBS MANY MORE AT THE
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND. THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD CHILDREN CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
BUT NOT SERVED BY SUBSIDIZED
EARLY LEARNING CARE PROGRAM.
THERE CRITICAL CONSIDERATIONS
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED TO MAKE
UNIVERSAL T. K. WORK FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES COMMUNITIES
AND SCHOOLS EXACTLY. HIGH
QUALITY PRESCHOOL LEARNING
EXPERIENCES REQUIRE INTENTIONAL
INVESTMENTS AND WELL QUALIFIED
EDUCATORS APPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENTS RESPONSIVE
INTERACTIONS CURRICULUM
INFORMED BY ONGOING
ASSESSMENTS. MEANINGFUL FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. WORK FOR MULTI
LINGUAL LEARNERS AND FOR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES THE
DECREASE TEACHER CHILD RATIO IN
THE ME REVISED PROPOSAL HELPS
WITH THAT BUT MORE ATTENTION TO
THE PROGRAM STANDARDS FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS IS NEEDED. THE
EXPANSION OF T. K. AS WELL AS
STABILIZATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OR C.
S. B. P. CREATES AN URGENT NEED
FOR AN ESTIMATED THOUSANDS OF
NEW TEACHERS AND EIGHT. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT ADEQUATE FUNDS
ARE ALLOCATED AND INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS ARE PUT INTO PLACE TO
SUPPORT THE EXISTING PRESCHOOL
WORKFORCE. THE BILL THESE JOBS
SINCE THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE ART IN
OUR DIVERSE BETTER REPRESENTING
THE CHILDREN THAT IS TYPICAL
FOR K. TWELVE. AND ALSO DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE IN
THEIR FIELD. YES COULD BE DONE
YOUR MANY OF THE PROGRAMS. AND
REFERRED TO IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL BUT ALSO CAN BE USED
THROUGH EXPANDING THE
CLASSIFIED TEACHER WORKFORCE
PROGRAM. INCLUDE A PATHWAY FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD PROFESSIONALS
FOR A TEACHING CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM. THE TICKET EXPERIENCE
MUST BE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE AND INCLUDES RICH
LEARNING EXPERIENCES THREE PLAY
INVESTMENT IN A PRESCHOOL
LEARNING FOUNDATIONS IN
CURRICULUM WILL HELP WITH THAT
AS WELL AS SOME COACHING
INVESTMENTS ON THAT SPECIAL ED
FINE. BUT JUST DEPORTING
INCLUSIVE PRACTICE. BUT WE
COULD EVEN EXPAND THINGS LIKE
THIS CALIFORNIA THE M. THE FTP
CURIS BLOCK GRANT SO THAT THERE
ARE SYSTEMS THAT ARE ALREADY
EXISTING. ECONOMIC SUPPORT NOT
JUST THE QUALITY OF STATE
PRESCHOOL BUT PROVIDE COACHING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORTS. TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS. HE
CAME WEST ALSO FAMILIES NEED
AND CHOICE. THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
PROPOSED AROUND UNITS AFTER
SCHOOL FOR T. AND MY SCHOOL.
WILL GO A LONG WAY SUPPORT THE
NEED FOR FAMILIES HAVE A FULL
DAY OF CARE. WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION THAT THERE WAS
EXPANDED LEARNING AFTER SCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES NEED TO HAVE
LOWER ADULT CHILD RATIOS IN THE
CURRENT. DO YOU. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE NEXT
A PARENTAL CHOICE IN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM FOR WHAT IT IS
CURRENTLY MANY PARENTS ARE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT PROVIDE
BETTER LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND PROGRAMS
THAT ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY
ACCESSIBLE HOURS THAT MEET
THEIR NEEDS FOR. PRESSING THE
COST PRESSURES WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT YOU CAN REDUCE YOUR
OVERALL EXPANSION OF ACCESS TO
RICH LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
INSTEAD OF LOSS OF CAPACITY.
AND THIS WILL REQUIRE PLANNING
AND INVESTMENT IN THE EXISTING
PRESCHOOL SYSTEM AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. MOVING ONTO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM DESPITE THE MAY REVISED
MAJOR INVESTMENT IN TEEKAY WE
KNOW THAT THE C. S. P. P.
PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
BIG PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRESCHOOL SYSTEM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS THEY DEVELOP
THEIR COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE OF C. S. B. P. IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE MASTER PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND ALSO
ENSURETHAT HEAD START AS PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION. A PART OF
STABILIZING THE FUTURE AND
AVAILABILITY OF THIS YEAR'S PPP
PROGRAM WILL BE ADDRESSING
COMPENSATION AND COSTS OF
PROVIDING QUALITY CARE. THERE
WERE A FEW ITEMS MISSING FROM
THE NAY REVISED PROPOSAL THAT I
WILL TOUCH BASE WITH. A SUPER
COLLAPSE. WELL WE APPRECIATE
RECEIVING A CALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS DID NOT
RECEIVE A COLOGNE LAST YEAR. IN
LIGHT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AROUND CAGE FILE AS
WELL AS HOW MUCH OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE STRUGGLING NOW WE
WOULD ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO
ALSO ALLOCATE SCENE COLLECTED
THE. S. B. P. ADVOCATE TWELVE.
IT IS THE P. P. RIGHT. ONE
PIECE THAT WE WILL NEED TO
ADDRESS AS A- THE CURRENCY S.
B. P. FROM GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS AND SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF THE MASTER PLAN. IS TO
ADDRESS THE CSP CARE RATE WHICH
IS FAR BEHIND THE T. K. RATE.
AS WELL AS BEHIND THE AVERAGE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. FOR NON
AND FOR THE VOUCHER BASED SIDE
OF OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM. EVEN
WITH THE PROPOSED COLA IN MAY
REVISED YES PP STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR S. R. R.
IS NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND LESS
PER CHILD. THAN THE AVERAGE ARM
OUR REGIONAL MARKET RATE FOR
THE SAME EACH CHILD IN A CARE
SETTING. CENTER BASED. AND IT'S
ALSO LESSEN THE AVERAGE FAMILY
CHILD CARE RATE NEITHER OF
WHICH ARE REQUIRED TO MEET THE
SAME LEVEL OF QUALITY. PROGRAM
STANDARDS ASKED THE SBP.
CORRECT THE PROCESS. WE KNOW
PROPOSAL WAS HEARD IN THE SPEND
THREE HEARING YESTERDAY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WHILE THE ME
REVISED PROVIDES TO CDSS WITH
SIX MILLION TO SUPPORT DIRECT
DEPOSIT PER CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
UNDER THEIR PURVIEW STARTING
JULY ONE. IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
SUPPORT FOR C. D. E. AND FOR
CSGP THESE WERE NEED TO BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE CVS S. B.
P. SO THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE
INEQUITIES TO OUR CONTRACTORS.
ALTERNATIVELY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES
CURRENTLY PLANNED FOR THIS TO
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
SAID THAT A STATEWIDE SOLUTION
THAT WOULD APPLY TO BOTH
DEPARTMENTS COULD BE DEVELOPED
WHILE CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN
TRANSPARENCY ESTATE ACCOUNTING
DATA. THROUGH THE FISCAL SYSTEM
INSTEAD OF NEEDING OUTSIDE OF
THAT. DATA THE CD WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DATA IT NEEDS
AROUND THE S. P. P. AND RIDE OF
CONNECTIONS TO CRADLE TO CAREER
AND THE MASTER PLAN GIRLS
AROUND PRESCHOOL TO THIRD GRADE
ALIGNMENT. FINALLY WE WANT TO
FLAG THAT THEY MAY REVISED
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT NEW
WORKLOAD AROUND UTK THE
PRESCHOOL LEARNING FOUNDATIONS
AS WELL AS THE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE. WITHOUT ADEQUATE
COURSE MONEY NEW STATE
OPERATION PRIME IN CONCLUSION
WE HAVE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THESE PROPOSALS TO HELP
STRENGTHEN THEM. AND ARE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS
YOU WORK TOWARDS FINALIZING
YOUR BUDGET PACKAGE. THIS
CONCLUDES. OUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH- AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO COME QUEST IN A
FEW A NEED TO SO OF SAY ABOUT
THE AT THE BEGINNING BECAUSE
THIS IS SUCH AN AMBITIOUS
PROPOSAL. THAT WE HAVE STATE
PRESCHOOL WE HAVE HAD START WE
HAVE OTHER CHILD CARE ARE WE
HAVE A TRANSITION IN THE WHOLE
QUESTION OF HOW EVERYTHING FITS
TOGETHER IT IS THIS IS JUST A
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION HERE AND
IT AND WHETHER WE ASK IT OR
NOT. EVERY INDIVIDUAL PIECE OF
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE AT THE HEART OF
WHATEVER THE DISCUSSIONS ARE
BECAUSE WELL WE SHARE GENERAL
DIRECTIONS- THOSE ARE ISSUES IN
FOR EXAMPLE LET ME ASK FINANCE
FIRST. AND THIS JUST
ILLUSTRATES A TRYING TO FIT IT
TOGETHER. THE IF THE PARENTS
WILL HAVE THE OPTION TO KEEP
THEIR FOUR YEAR OLDS IN STATE
PRESCHOOL HEAD START OR OTHER
CHILD CARE. EVEN IF THEY ARE
AGE ELIGIBLE FOR T. K. AND
WHETHER THAT'S EITHER DURING
THE TRANSITION AFTER HOW DOES
THAT FIT TOGETHER. AND THERE
ARE THIS IS JUST GO HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
SO THE IDEA HERE WHERE WE'RE
NOT PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE FOUR
YEAR OLD ELIGIBILITY IN THE
OTHER- EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
AND WE'RE NOT PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE FOR ELIGIBILITY- FOR
ANY OF THAT THE SUBSIDIZED
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS. ON HEAD
START OR- STATE PRESCHOOL AND
TO RETAIN PARENT CHOICE. I
CAN'T SPEAK TO- YOU KNOW
SEVERAL YEARS DOWN THE ROAD- I
CAN'T SPEAK TO WEAR ON THE
STATE MAY DECIDE TO GO WITH
THOSE PROGRAMS BUT FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE- WE ARE
PLANNING ON- AT RETAINING THAT
ELIGIBILITY I WILL SAY THAT FOR
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR. WE ARE- WE ARE AT
IT AND PROPOSING THAT IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET-
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
WE WILL DEVELOP A PLAN. TO HELP
PROVIDERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING SERVICES- THROUGH THE
C. S. P. PROGRAM TO SERVE MORE
YOUNGER CHILDREN WITH THE
RECOGNITION THAT. WILL LIKELY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
RATES UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
RATIOS FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN ARE
MUCH DIFFERENT. THAN THEY ARE
FOR YOUR CHILDREN SO THAT IS-
PART OF AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
AND- CERTAINLY YOU KNOW ALL OF
ALL OF OUR PROPOSALS ARE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EARLY LEARNING CARE SO IN
TERMS OF. HOW THESE PIECES FIT
TOGETHER ON THAT THERE
CERTAINLY IS THAT A LOGIC IN A
PLAN BEHIND IT- BUT FOR NOW
THAT. WE ARE WE ARE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PARENT CHOICE AND
RETAINING THE ELIGIBILITY.
THOSE PROGRAMS FROM. THAT OF
BILL. THAT IS WITH. IT IT LET
ME. ASK ONE UP JUST ON THAT
SPECIFIC POINT BECAUSE YOU SAID
YOU CAN'T. BOB WHATEVER THE
WORD WAS USED YOU CAN'T FORESEE
INTO THE FUTURE AND NO WAY INTO
THE FUTURE WHAT WILL HAPPEN
BUT- BOB WHAT WE CAN IS IF
THERE'S A TRANSITION. AND WE
GET. OUR- YOU KNOW THE EARLY
EDUCATION PROPOSAL UP. DOES
THAT PRESUME THAT YOU'RE
ALLOWING- PARENTAL CHOICE AFTER
THE TRANSITION BECAUSE THAT IS
PART OR SHOULD BE PART OF THE
PLAN NOW A DESCRIPTION OF WHERE
WHAT THAT IS SO WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF THE PROGRAM GOES
COMPLETELY UP WITH PARENTAL
CHOICE ON THE OTHER PROGRAMS
WOULD THAT CONTINUE. AFTER THE
TRANSITION TO A FULLY BEING UP.
SO OUR OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL
ROUTINES RETAINS THE PARENTAL
CHOICE- REGARDLESS OF WHERE
WE'RE AT THE TIKI TRANSITION I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- CURRENTLY
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AT FIVE.
UNDER FIVE YEARS OLD AND OLDER
CAN ACCESS- ALL OF OUR
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
AND SO WE WOULD SEE FOUR YEAR
OLDS- FOLLOWING THAT THAT SAME
LOGIC. IN OUR ENERGY AS
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE PROGRAMS-
I THINK YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO PREDICT THE
FUTURE CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY MAKE
CHANGES IN HEAD START- THAT I
CAN'T PREDICT- AND- IT MAY BE
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
PROPOSAL TO. INTEGRATE STATE
PRESCHOOL WITH SOME OTHER CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS- IN THE FUTURE
THAT THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS- I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME BILLS OUT THERE- THAT
THAT LOOK AT SORT OF THE ZERO
TO THREE POPULATION. I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHERE THOSE ARE
GOING TO GO SO THAT'S WHAT I
MEANT BY NOT BEING ABLE TO
PREDICT THE FUTURE BUT THIS
PROPOSAL ASSUMES. THAT FOUR
YEAR OLD ELIGIBILITY FOR AT THE
EXISTING CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
WILL REMAIN INTACT- DURING THE
TRANSITION AND AFTERWARDS AND I
GET THAT WE CAN'T PREDICT WHAT
OTHER ENTITIES ARE DOING OR
EVEN THE STATE LEGISLATURE ON
CERTAIN PIECES OF THIS GOING
FORWARD BUT WE KNOW WHAT WE
KNOW NOW. AND WITH YOUR PLAN
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW NOW. IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE ABSENT ANY
OTHER CHANGES IT IS YOUR PLAN
TO CONTINUE PARENTAL CHOICE AND
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CASE THAT
A CORRECT STATEMENT THAT IS A
CORRECT STATEMENT YES OKAY. ARE
THANK YOU AND IT BUT IT
ACCENTUATES HOW THERE'S SO MANY
DETAILS ABOUT THIS THAT THAT
JUST PROPOSING IT IS NOT ENOUGH
IT IS ROSY. SORT OF FLUSHING
OUT THESE DETAILS SO THERE'S
CLARITY FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S PHASED IN
BY AGE GROUP- OVER NUMBER OF
YEARS AND FINALLY THERE WERE BE
AND IT. TO BORN BUT OCT TO.
AND- IT IN THE SYSTEM BUT ARM.
HE I THINK THAT THAT WERE
REALLY GOING TO WANT TO DRIVE
SOME OF THESE TO GROUND IT IF
WE'RE GOING TO. APPROVE THIS
AND I MEAN JUST ONE RANDOM
QUESTION IS. FOR EXAMPLE. ON T.
K. AS EACH ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
REQUIRED TO OFFER T. K. UNDER
THIS PLAN OR IS IT ONLY ONE
SITE PER DISTRICT. SO THAT THE
WE'RE NOT PROPOSING ANY CHANGES
TO THE CURRENT CONSTRUCT OF
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
REQUIREMENTS UNDER TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN SO THE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT EVERY ALLEY A IS
I'M REQUIRED TO GIVE ACCESS. TO
ALL. FOUR YEAR OLDS TO T. K.
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY I THINK IT
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE SMALL
NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT
PARTICIPATE IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN MANY ELEAZAR DO
NOT PROVIDE ACCESS TO T. K.
EVERY SITE HOWEVER GIVEN- THAT
WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO THAT PROGRAM- MUCH
MORE LIKELY THAT- ALL. ALL LEDS
WILL HAVE TO UTILIZE THE SPACE
THAT AT ALL THEIR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS ON TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS SO- WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING ANY CHANGES- TO THE
CURRENT LAW- HOWEVER GIVEN THE
INCREASE IN MAGNITUDE OF
STUDENTS BEING SERVED IT'S
LIKELY THAT WHAT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE CURRENTLY WILL NOT BE WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE. ON A FEW YEARS
AND THEN THAT RAISES THE
QUESTION THAT IF BEFORE
TRANSITIONING OVER A FEW YEARS
AND WE HAVE LOW STUDENTS TO
ADULT RATIOS. OF INDIE NT K.
TEACHERS HAVE EARLY CHILDHOOD.
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE. HOW DO WE-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE- WITH
THOSE REQUIREMENTS TO HAVE THE
PEOPLE AND- THE EDUCATION DONE
IN TIME TO STAND THIS UP THE
WAY IT IS PROJECTED IN THIS
TIME. FOR THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND YOU KNOW EAT. IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR
PROPOSALS REGARDING A TEACHER
AT PREPARATION IN TEACHER
RECRUITMENT- THAT IS CERTAINLY
TIED TO THIS AND DOES INCLUDE-
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AS-
YOU KNOW A CREDENTIAL THAT WORK
WE'RE TRYING TO RECRUIT WE'RE
TRYING TO- I BRING PEOPLE ON
BOARD AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE
CERTAINLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
FOR SOME- ELEAZAR. THE TWENTY
FOUR UNITS AT EASE YOU MAY BE A
BARRIER WERE HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT WHAT
MAKES SENSE IN TERMS OF. OF YOU
KNOW ROLLING THAT REQUIREMENT
OUT AND THAT IT WOULD JUST
WOULD NOTE THAT THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF PERSON THAT NEEDS TO BE
IN THE CLASSROOM CAN BE
CLASSIFIED STAFF. PERSON OR
CERTIFICATES APPERSON THIS. ON
THEIR- A BROADER POOL AND THE
BILL WORKFORCE I'M FOR THAT
POSITION. KARAMANA ARE I THINK
IT'S AN EXAM. THAT IT'S TO BE A
CHIU- ME WHY ARE I COULD GO ON
WITH SOME OF THESE QUESTION BUT
I I'VE TO WHERE I'VE- TO GO
WHICH IS. HELLO BIT OF.
SIGNALING TO THAT THERE'S
CONCERN ABOUT THE THIS RELATES
TO THE OTHER. THAT THERE'S GOOD
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
LOT OF DETAIL THAT SOME OF THE
IMPEDIMENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO BE ADDRESSED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COULD DO THIS AND HAVE
SOME CHECK AND TO KNOW HOW WE
ARE DOING. OUR AT THOSE
DIFFERENT TIMES AND- IT IT JUST
IS A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION ABOUT
THE INTEGRATION- BECAUSE THAT
THAT MAYBE ONE. OR LAST FOLLOW
UP TO MISS HOLMES. IF WE
OFFERED THE PARENTAL CHOICE AND
CONTINUE ALL THESE ARE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS. DO YOU HAVE
ANY PRESUMPTION AS PART OF YOUR
PROPOSAL ABOUT HOW MANY WOULD
BE ANTI K. AS OPPOSED TO THE
OTHER PROGRAMS I MEAN WHAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE SECTORS ARE.
IN WHO WOULD BE WHERE.
CERTAINLY SO I CAN SHARE- OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD I CAN SHARE
OUR- ESTIMATES FOR AND HOW MANY
FOUR YEAR OLDS WOULD MOVE OVER
TO TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
OF WHAT I CAN'T PROVIDE WITH
ANY LEVEL OF ACCURACY OR
PRECISION IS ON HOW MANY MIGHT
BE RETAINED I'M IN THE OTHR
PROGRAMS- BECAUSE WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE A GREAT SENSE OF HOW
MANY STUDENTS- WILL WANT TO
STAY- IN THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS THAT SUBSIDIZE CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE-
OUTSIDE OF T. K. BUT WE ARE. WE
ARE ATICIPATING THAT-
APPROXIMATELY APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND FOUR
YEAR OLDS- WHAT WILL BE COMING
INTO THE T. K. SYSTEM UPON FULL
IMPLEMENTATION- THAT MAY TAKE A
FEW YEARS TO- TO. MATERIALIZE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ROLL OUT OF
T. K. WHEN IT WAS FIRST- COMING
INTO BEING- ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO- WE SLOWLY KIND OF
INCREASED- THAT. THAT AT. THE
FOUR YEAR OLD WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING I'M AS MORE
PARENTS BECAME AWARE OF ITS
EXISTENCE AND OUR CHILD
ELIGIBILITY- SO THAT TOOK A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME BUT ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION WERE
DISTRIBUTING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND. ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS AND PART OF TE REASON
WHY I CAN'T GET A GREAT AT
NUMBER ON THE OTHER PROGRAMS
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH HOW MANY KIDS
WE ARE. ANTICIPATING WILL STAY
IN THOSE PROGRAMS IS BECAUSE
TKA HAS OPEN ELIGIBILITY FOR
ANY STUDENT AND THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE MEANS TESTED SO THEY DO
HAPPEN INCOME ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. SO IT'S HARD TO
MEASURE THE IMPACT THE
DIFFERENCE AN IMPACT ON
FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY FOR THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS VERSUS. I'M
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW THE TOTAL
AN INFLUX OF KIDS FROM ALL
INCOME LEVELS. OKAY I JUST
THINK THAT SIGNALS- A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS WERE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAPPEN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR MAN. FOR
QUESTIONS FOR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- FROM ITS FIRST
CLASSROOM SPACE- THIS THIS YOUR
BUDGET CONTEMPLATES JUST THE
NEED TO ACQUIRE OR BUILD OUT
MORE PHYSICALS INFRASTRUCTURE.
CERTAINLY YES THE DESK HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
PER WE INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REDUCE THAT
BY ABOUT TEN MILLION TO COVER
THE COST OF PRESCHOOL LEARNING
FOUNDATION UPDATES YEAH- BUT WE
HAVE A HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
FOR- TKA FACILITIES AND THEN
THE REVISION. THANK YOU FOR
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT- AND
THEN I GUESS I THINK I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- WAS IT IS NOBLE
MORGAN I THINK YOU'VE
REFERENCED- SOME OF THE STUDIES
AROUND T. K. AND I'M SURE THOSE
ARE ARE RIGHT WE KNOW EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS SUPER
IMPORTANT- CENTER LEARN KIND
OF. ALLUDED TO THE THERE
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A TRADE
OFF HERE BETWEEN. HIGHER
QUALITY EDUCATION VISITED
SHOPPED HERE RIGHT AND I GUESS.
THE QUESTION IN A MOVIE ST THE
RADICAL BUT- YOU KNOW IF WE
WERE TO PRIORITIZE UNIVERSAL T.
K. R. FOR UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE.
WHICH OF THOSE WILL HAVE LIKE
BETTER PEDAGOGICAL AL COMES
DOWN THE LINE IS TO SAY. OR IS
IT MORE IMPORTANT TO JUST HAVE
PEOPLE WATCHING YOU IN SORT OF-
REGULATED SAY SPACES WHAT WHAT
WHAT IS IT WHAT IS A RESEARCHER
ON THIS AS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO PROCEED. SO WHEN I DON'T
WANT TO DO IS GET INTERIOR FOR
THE WARS THAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
ACCESSING QUALITY. BUT WHAT I
CAN DO IS SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
RESEARCH FAMILIES NEED BOTH
THEY NEED THEIR CHILDREN. TO
WATCH WHILE THEY'RE AT WORK BUT
THOSE WORK THOSE SETTINGS. NEED
TO BE HIGH QUALITY AND
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ARE
HOME BASED SCHOOL BASED. AND
PRICE TAG. IN THE COMMUNITY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TEACHERS HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS. REPORT THE
RESOURCES. WE CAN ENGAGE IN
RESPONSIVE INTERACTIONS.
ESPECIALLY AS CHILDREN GROW
OLDER THAT THEY REALLY USE
CURRICULUM THAT IS INFORMED BY
THE CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT. AND
THAT IT'S AN ONGOING ASSESSMENT
PIECE. SO WORKING IN THIS FIELD
YOU REALLY DO NEED RESOURCES
SUPPORTS EDUCATION. AND
RESEARCH CLEARLY SHOWS HOW MUCH
THAT IS HE SAYS MATTER
ESPECIALLY MOST OF ITS TARGET
PRESCHOOL RESEARCH WITH THE
BOSTON PUBLIC SCHOOL WHEN JUST
COMING OUT. THIS WEEK ORLAST
WEEK WITH VERY STRONG OUTCOMES
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY INTENTIONAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THAT
ACTUALLY STARTS WITH G. I THINK
IT'S A FOR YOU ALSO MIGHT BE
THE THRILLS BUT ALSO GOES
THROUGH KINDERGARTEN FIRST
GRADE. SO THAT THEY HAVE
ALIGNMENT IN CURRICULUM AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S ALSO SOME RESEARCH TO
SHOW THAT TEACHER COMPENSATION.
AND HOW YOU SUPPORT THE
EDUCATORS CAN PASS BOTH IN
RETENTION AS WELL AS- BEING
ABLE TO GET THE TEACHERS WITH
THOSE LEVELS OF EDUCATION THAT
YOU MIGHT NEED. I APPRECIATE
THAT I GUESS I JUST. WOULD FALL
ON CENTER LAYERS COMMONSENSE.
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL WANT. TEEKAY
THANK AN IMPORT PRIOR AND I PUT
THIS AFTER FROM THE PART FINING.
AT THIS TIME. YOU KNOW IT A LOT
OF FAMILIES THERE WHERE THREE
HOURS A CHILD CARE OR THREE
HOURS A T. K. REALLY DOESN'T
HELP THEIR TRUCKERS SITUATION
AND- THAT THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO BE. THINKING
ABOUT AS WELL AND- SO I
APPRECIATE THAT I LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
TOPIC AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CAN JUST SAY ONE MORE THING
THAT I REALLY DO THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAT
WENT OUT ON THAT EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TIME. SO
THAT FAMILIES WHO WORKS USING
T. K. WOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT IMMEDIATE PICK UP
BUT THAT THE SCHOOL SITE EXCEL.
COULD ADD ON WHAT WE CALL THE
ASUS PROGRAM. BUT HAVE IT BE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
WITH THAT SMALLER RATIO FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN CHILDREN. SO
THERE'S A LOT THAT I FEEL LIKE
THE MASTER PLAN CALLED OUT IN
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED IN THIS.
THAT HELPS THINK AROUND ABOUT
THAT THAT FAMILIES AREN'T
HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT. I'M AT
WORK AND I HAVE A JOB WHERE I
CAN'T LEAVE TO GO PICK UP AND
MOVE MY CHILD BUT ACTUALLY CAN
USE T. K. AS EIGHT EIGHT PART
OF MY CHOICE SETTING TYPE. AND
THEN HAVE THAT CHILD WRAPPED
AROUND WITH OTHER. CARE SO THAT
I CAN STAY AT WORK. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE BURKE THE COMMENTS
ON THAT ITEM. AND I THINK IF WE
REALLY DRILL DOWN FURTHER WE
COULD GO ON FOR A FEW HOURS ON
THIS BUT I THINK THE MAJOR
CONCERNS WERE RAISED TO THE BE
THE DISCUSSION AS WE- WE MOVED
TO DO. THIS BUDGET ITEM SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE LAST
ISSUE WHICH IS OTHER K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION PROPOSALS AND
TO BE QUITE HONEST. WITH
ANYTHING THAT DIDN'T FIT
ANYWHERE ELSE THAT SORT OF OUR
OUR CLOSES US OFF HERE SO- THAT
IS THE COMMON THEME. THIS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE SEVEN AND I
HAVE LISTED- FOR PEOPLE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALEK
SHOPE WAS MAY AMBER ALEXANDER
INVOICE BEING. AND TO FROM THE
L. A. O. SARAH CORTEZ NAMELY
AND ELLIE GARNER FROM. CD SO-
LET'S BEGIN ITEM ISSUE SEVEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN WHATEVER ORDER HOWEVER YOU
WISH TO PERCENT. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE- MORE MISTER CHAIR
AND OUT CHAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO I'LL PRESENT ON THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS FOR-
NUTRITION OF FOSTER YOUTHS AND
THEN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AMBER ALEXANDER- TO
COVER PROPOSALS FOR SAID- CT
AND ASSESSMENTS. SO THE MAY
REVISION BUILDS TOWARDS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME
ELIGIBILITY. BY INVESTING IN
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- TO INCENTIVIZE
ELLIE AS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EXISTING FEDERAL UNIVERSAL-
YOU'LL PROVISIONS-
INCENTIVIZING PARTICIPATION IN
THESE EXISTING PROVISIONS WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS SUSTAINABLE. BY MAXIMIZING
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS- WE INTENDED FOR THIS
INCOME INCREASED REIMBURSEMENT
TO MAKE PARTICIPATION. IN THE
FEDERAL MIL PROVISIONS- MORE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE FOR ELEAZAR-
THAT WANT TO PARTICIPATE AND
ALSO TO REDUCE. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND
COLLECTING MEAL APPLICATIONS-
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE. JUST
BROKE RACIAL PROVIDE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE CENT
REIMBURSEMENT. FOR MEALS SERVED
UNDER THESE PROGRAMS TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS- IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING THE STUDENTS WITH
ACCESS TO MEALS WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE MEALS THEY HAVE
OUR FRESH NUTRITIOUS- TO THIS
AND- THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- ONE TIME FROM NINETY
EIGHT TO INVEST IN STAFF
TRAINING- ON FOOD PREPARATION.
MùT NUTRITIOUS FOODS HEALTHY
FOOD MARKET IN. AS WELL AS-
KITCHEN EQUIPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THE
PREPARATION OF QUALITY SCHOOL
MEALS AND THE ABILITY TO STORE
FRESH FOODS. FINALLY WE WERE
JUST NOTE THAT THE MAY REVISION
ALSO INCLUDES THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- THE FAR TO SCHOOL
PROGRAM. MOVING TO FOSTER USE
SERVICES- QUICKLY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROP NINETY EIGHT TO FIND
DIRECT SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR FOSTER YOUTH- THIS FUNDING
WOULD BE ALLOCATED TO FOSTER
YOUTH SERVICES COORDINATING
PROGRAMS AT COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION UNDER THE EXISTING
PROGRAM- SERVICE THAT I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
AMBER ALEXANDER HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
ALEXANDER. THANK YOU ALEX AND
AS MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA- I'M
SORRY SHOULD INTRODUCE MYSELF
AGAIN AMBER ALEXANDER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
MENTIONED THE AGENDA THERE ARE
SEVERAL NOTABLE INVESTMENTS IN
THE MAY REVISION FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION I'M INCLUDING AN
APPLICATION OF A COMPOUNDED
FOUR POINT 005% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AS WELL AS THE
ALLOCATION OF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL AND STATE- LEVEL
RESOURCES. TO IMPROVE
INSTRUCTION AND SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ADDITIONALLY IN THE AREA OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES EIGHTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OPERATED BY
TWENTY FIRST AUTHORITIES. AND
THIS INVESTMENT IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE C. T. E. J. P. AS WITH
SOME RELIEF AS THEY WORK TO
KEEP STAFF AND STUDENTS SAFE
AND COMPLY WITH KOBE NINETEEN
PROTOCOLS- AND FINELY IN THE
MAYOR VERSION INCLUDES SEVERAL
OTHER PROPOSALS AND INVESTMENTS
IN AREAS INCLUDING ASSESSMENTS
CURRICULA- IN TECHNOLOGY TO
NAME A FEW AN INTEREST OF TIME
I WILL NOT GO THROUGH THOSE
PROPOSALS BUT THEY ARE OUTLINED
IN IN YOUR AGENDA AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL- FOLKS FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON THE- ON SOUMETTRE
HAVE. TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND DOES
THAT COME. THE ANYONE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SPEAKING
ON THE SIDELINES. MORE PEOPLE
LISTED I'M ASSUMING THEY'RE
HERE FOR QUESTIONS YES I
COMPLETES OUR FORMAL
PRESENTATION BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS OKAY THEN
WE'LL GO TO SARAH CORTEZ OF THE
FOLIO. THE MORNING CARE CORTEZ
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE JUST HAVE A
SHORTCOMING- REGARDING THE ON
GOING SHOULD PROPOSAL WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND A RARE REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT PREJUDICE THE
PROPOSAL DOES MAKE A MAJOR
CHANGE THE RATE STRUCTURE WITH
LIMITED TIME TO REVIEW. THAT
ALSO NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS DIFFERENT- THEN THE
PROPOSAL DISCUSSED DURING
HEARING EARLIER THIS MONTH- SO
NOW I'D LIKE TO HEADED OFF TO
MY COLLEAGUE AMY LEAD TO SHARE
THE REMAINDER OF THE COMMENTS
ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU ANYWAY
WHAT THE L. A. L. ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE ONLY HAVE ONE
COMMENT RELATED TO THIS SPECIAL
EDUCATION INCLUSIVE. SETTINGS
WORK GROUPS. ON THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE INCLUDES VERY FEW
DETAILS OF THE LEGISLATURE ME
ONCE AGAIN WANT TO. I CONSIDER
MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE TO
CLARIFY THE WORK DELIVERABLES
INCLUDING THE REPORTING
DEADLINES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THEN WILL MOVE
TO- ONLY GARNER OF THE CD.
THANK YOU CHARLIE GARNER ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
AGAIN MANY OF THE PROPOSALS AND
THE MAJOR REVISION ALIGN WITH
CIRCLES OF THE SS PI. THE FBI
S. S. P. A. IS INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL TO SEE THAT THE ME
REALIZE INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR THE
STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS WHICH
COULD NOT OTHERWISE BENEFIT
FROM MANY OF THE KOBE CARE ACT.
ON EMERGENCY INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION THAT THE MAINTENANCE
IS ESPECIALLY APPRECIATED.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF TOPICS
THAT MAKE UP THIS ITEM I DO
WANT TO TAKE A FEW MOMENTS TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS A FEW
PROPOSALS IN PARTICULAR-
REGARDING THE UNIVERSAL MEALS
THE ONGOING STATE COMMITMENT OF
A HUNDRED AND L. HUNT ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS. AND A HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TRAINING
FUNDING STARTS IS ON THE RIGHT
PATHWAY TO LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS IN OUR CHILDREN'S
OVERALL WELLBEING AND ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. BY BREAKING DOWN FOOD
ACCESS BARRIERS. FOR THE MORE
SUCCESS IN THIS AREA IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
ADDRESSING THE OPPORTUNITY GAP
AS STUDIES CONFIRM THAT THERE
IS INCREASED PARTICIPATION IN
THE SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS FROM
ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
ECONOMIC STATUS. ALL CHILDREN
EAT FOR FREE. THERE ARE HOWEVER
THE- TO THE TWENTY FIVE CENT
PER KRIPO. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL. WONDER
STUDENTS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
REACH THEIR FULL ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL HAVE GREATER HEALTH
OUTCOMES THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE.
THE OTHER ITEM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW IS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
WE WANT TO AGAIN COMMENDED THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. BUT WE JUST-NEED THAT THE 50% MATCH
REQUIREMENT NEED BE AN ISSUE
FOR A NUMBER OF LEDS IN
APPLYING FOR THE FUNDS. WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT CITIES TIMELINE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION WILL BE
REALLY DEPENDENT ON THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDS AVAILABLE. THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT JUMP FROM THE
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
MILLION PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS AND CONDITIONS. TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS CAN
BE FULLY SUPPORT IT. SO WITH
THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARM. WELL LET ME.
MAKE A COMMENT AND THEN ASK A
SPECIFIC QUESTION IN THE
COMMENT IS I NOTE THE L. A.
O.'S COMMENTS ABOUT STILL
LACKING DETAILS ABOUT MANY
THINGS AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE
GONNA WANNA. HAVE THEM AND IT
MAY GOVERN WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
R. ONE SOME OF THOSE DETAILS
BECOME CLEARER AND JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AND FOR
FINANCE OF THERE IS THE
PROPOSAL. ARE YOU HERE. FOR
ADDITIONAL PROP NINETY EIGHT OF
FOUR OF THE L. A. AGE TO
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OF THE
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL PROVISIONS
AND I WONDERED. HOW MANY
SCHOOLS DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
ASSUME WOULD EXPAND TO THIS
PATTERN. BOB A SCHOOL SIDE
GIVEN THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS I
MEAN WHAT'S THE SCALE OF WHAT
COULD BE DONE BY THIS
RECOMMENDATION REQUEST. THANK
YOU ALLEN CHAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I THINK- WE WOULDN'T
KNOW FIRST THAT THERE IS
ALREADY FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT-
PARTICIPATION IN THESE
UNIVERSAL MAIL PROGRAMS- E DID
FACTOR AND- GROSS I THINK. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ACCOUNT FOR OVER
FOUR THOUSAND SCHOOLS- BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE- AND SURVEYING-
OVER- TWO TWO MILLION CLOSER TO
AN HAVE- MILLIONS TOTAL COVERED
BY THESE PROVISIONS N. N. WHEN
YOU SAID FOUR THOUSAND IS A
THAT FOUR THOUSAND NEW SCHOOLS.
I KNOW THAT BAG IS. TOTAL DO
YOU KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT
NUMBER IS IT'S FROM WHAT TO
FOUR THOUSAND. I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC NUMBER- RIGHT IN FRONT
OF ME- BUT I DID I THINK JUST
AS A BALLPARK WOULD BE- AN
INCREASE OF- SEVERAL HUNDRED
SCHOOLS- AND PROBABLY I THANK-
BREASTS. MAYBE ABOUT FIFTEEN
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE PRECISE
NUMBERS BECAUSE I THINK IT
WOULD HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
SCALE RELATED TO THE MONEY. I'M
ASSUMING THE SILENCES YES
YOU'LL PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
TO THE- OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
YEAH ARE THEN I'LL ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS ON ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS AN ISSUE. SEVEN THEN I
DON'T SEE ANY SO. LET ME JUST-
THANK THE PANELISTS AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AS DETAILS
BECOME CLEARER WE WILL- WE
WON'T ARE. FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
DO AND LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
DETAILS AND I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT IN A
MOMENT. AND THE END SO OUR
MAJOR- PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
INFLUENCE US BUT BASED ON WHAT
WE'VE HEARD THUS FAR LET ME
JUST MAKE A FEW SUMMARY
COMMENTS WHICH IS. WITH THIS
AMOUNT OF GROWTH IN THE MONEY
WOULD LOVE TO SEE PAYING OFFTHE DEFERRALS. I THINK THAT.
THE BECAUSE WITH ALL THE L. E.
A. SUPPORTING STE STUDENTS
RETURNING AND THEN HAVING A LOT
OF NEW PROGRAMS WITH NEW
REQUIREMENTS WERE GOING TO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE CAPACITY AND
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT. AND AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER WILL BE
INTERESTED IN THE- A. N. OF
WHETHER OR NOT SPECIAL
EDUCATIONAL OFFSETS OR
THINGS THAT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
FOR FURTHER CONTRIBUTIONS. AND
THEN LOOK AT THE SYSTEM THAT'S
PROPOSED FOR TKA AND WHETHER
IT'S A TRULY. MAKES DELIVERY
SYSTEMATICALLY SAID ARE AND
WHETHER WE NEED TO BUILD UP THE
OTHER ONES IF WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THEM THERE AS WELL AS
DOING TO. THE TKA OF FOR
PARENTAL OPTION SO I HOPE THAT.
THAT WE WILL HAVE DISCUSSIONS
THOSE ISSUES THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE HEADLINES IT CAME
OUT AN ADDITIONAL. WE ARE CALL
TENSION BACK TO THE COMMENT
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT IF
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE ALL THESE
NEW PROGRAMS- WE REALLY NEED TO
KNOW HOW THEY WILL BE MEASURED
AND WHAT THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE. AND HOW
WE AS AN OVERSIGHT BODY IS PART
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS WILL BE
ABLE TO MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS. OF ALL OF THESE
AS THE START DECEPTIVELY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US WE DID ASK FOR
SOME UPDATED INFORMATION. IN
THE PREVIOUS ITEM AND WHEN WE
KNOW ABOUT A TEACHER
RETIREMENTS AND SOME OTHERS AS
IT WENT ALONG AND I WOULD JUST
CALL THAT OUT AGAIN. BECAUSE OF
THAT WE DO THAT WITH THAT ARE I
THINK WE WILL MOVE TO. PUBLIC.
COMMENT AND THE N. WE- ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE OUT OF THE ROOM
AND NOT TO DISTANT FUTURE SO I
WILL. I WILL ASSESS THE LENGTH
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT THE
MODERATOR TELLS ME LINE FOR MY
NOT BUT FIRST BEFORE GOING TO
THE MODERATOR. I WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
THAT WISHES TO COMMENT ON THE
ITEMS THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
SINAN I WILL GO TO A ROOM ON
TWELVE. SEEING NO ONE THEN
MODERATOR ARE WE WILL GO TO
YOU- THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYBODY TO COMMENT ON THE
ITEMS THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
AND- AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
YOUR BEST ASSESSMENT OF THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
QUEUE AFTER A MINUTE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE ABSOLUTELY AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE FIFTEEN LINES
IN Q. AND IF I MAY- GIVE A
REMINDER TO THOSE ON THE
TELEPHONE LINES IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN EIGHTEEN
T. SECIALIST WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND WOULD
YOU A LINE WILL BE OPENED UP
WHEN YOU ARE CALLED UPON
MODERATOR TIME WE COULD HAVE
NINE. NINETEEN WE DO HAVE
NINETEEN LINES IN Q. AND LET ME
JUST SAY THAT BASED ON WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY. FONG WE
WOULD BE LUCKY IF THAT'S JUST
HALF BY THE TIME WE'RE DONE
AND- AND SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS- LET EVERYBODY KNOW THAT-
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A THIRTY
SECOND LIMIT. AND SUGGEST IS
THE BEST YOU CAN. DO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THE GENERAL
GIST AND WILL ALLOW AND
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE. TO REVISE AND
EXTEND THEIR- REMARKS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE SO
THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU BUT WE ALSO. THERE'S
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. IN THIS
HEARING ROOM LATER AND THEY
HAVE TO DO A LAMBERT SAID UP
FOR BECAUSE I KNOW I'M ON THAT
COMMITTEE. A. N. SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALLOW ENOUGH
TIME FOR THAT TO HAPPEN SO THE
PRO TEM DOESN'T ASK ME WHY
SHE'S STARTING HER COMMITTEE
WHITE. SO A MODERATOR LET'S
MOVE TO THE CALLERS AND AS LONG
AS WE CAN TAKE IT WILL GO FOR
THIRTY SECONDS EACH AND IF IT
TURNS OUT THERE'S A LOT LIKE
YOU MAY HAVE TO CUT IT OFF AT
SOME POINT BUT- OUR MODERATOR
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH.
SOURCE THANK YOU ALLY TWENTY
NINE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
BELIEVES HE WITH THAT BOY YOU
RECOMMEND ATTENDED BY DOWN A
100% A DEFERRAL FIND OUT OF
THIS WORLD NOW SEE DOING THE
DOLLAR GRANT FUTURE WHEN IT'LL
BE NEEDED TO TWO POINT SIX
BILLION FOR A FEW WEEKS SOUNDS
LIKE NO BIG DEAL DONNA CASH
BASIS OUT ACROSS THE STATE OVER
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO GET
OFF. THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND MORE IF IT ISN'T PAID OFF
THEN THE LONGER THE DEFERRAL
CONTINUE THE MORE RISK FUTURE
BUDGET CUTS NOT JUST CASH CUTS
WILL BE PAID BY TEACHERS
INSURANCE. THE STATE CAN AVOID
THOSE CUTS BY ELIMINATING THE
DEBT NOW AND BUILDING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT GOING IN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. LINE
THIRTY. HI ANNA WITHOUT
ADVOCATE WE APPLY THE MULTI
INVEST TO PROVIDE RESTORATIVE
TARGET SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS I
WOULD HAVE ARTICULATED A THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH AN
EXPAND COMMUNITY CALL
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR THE
FUTURE OF LEARNING MEDICAMENTS
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROPOSAL IN
PARTICULAR WE RECOMMEND SETTING
ASIDE MORE FIND BACK 95% OF THE
MINIMUM STRUGGLING TO PASS THE
EVERY LEVEL OF THIS DAM
INCLUDING A STATEWIDE ADVISORY
COUNCIL FUNDS TO BUILD STATE MY
CAPACITY AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TO EXPAND THE
REGIONAL TECHNICAL. EIGHT WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT ADDED WEIGHT
TO BE GIVEN TO THE APPLICANT
ARE YOU SEE THAT LAST REVIEWED
YOUR CHARGES ARE CRITICAL
PROBLEM AND WE DO SUPPORT THE
THREE POINT THREE BILLION FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION VERY MUCH
GRAHAM. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR. NEXT
CALL. WHAT ONE THIRTY ONE. I
THOUGHT FROM TODAY NO REPORTER
CHRIS KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET EUROBIKE
UNIVERSE PRE FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLD- IT APPRECIATE THE
COMMUNITY IS BIG ABOUT HOW THE
IMPLEMENTED. REALLY HE
OPPORTUNITY BOB HERTZBERG ALL
FOUR YEAR OLD AND THEN YOU
START THE DAY. THE PROPOSED
HELP SIR. OUT THANK YOUNG THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH%
MODERATE NEXT WHAT. BY THIRTY
THREE. DONNA WITH CNC WE WANTED
KNOWLEDGE WHICH POSITIVE IN
THIS INCLUDING UNIVERSAL PRE K.
5% OF OUR EXPECT THEM PUT ME IN
COLLEGE AND ALL KEEP UP
CHEMICAL SHOULD RECEIVE THE AS
WELL THE CLASS AMERICA'S PRO
SHOULD BE MADE ON GOING SO THAT
DISTRICT AND BACK DOWN SECURE
IN THEIR PARTICIPATION. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION PARTS PER
E-MAIL REIMBURSEMENT FALL SHORT
OF THE TRUE COST OF A UNIVERSAL
HEALTH PROGRAM WHICH IS CLOSER
TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION LASTLY
A QUESTION THE STAFFING PLAN
SHOULD BE DEDICATED FOR
CUSTODIAL STAFF TO MEET.
NECESSARY CLEAN THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE CON
MORE NECK CALL. THANK YOU THAT
WILL COME FROM NINE TO GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING NINE HUNDRED AND
WITH WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING OUT GOING A TRADITION
WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THE
PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN FEDERAL
UNIVERSAL MEAL PROGRAM. AS WELL
AS THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME INVESTMENT IN SCHOOL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
AND TRAINING FOR STAFF THESE
ARE IMPORTANT FIRST STEPS THAT
WILL HELP EXPAND ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZED SCHOOL MEALS AND
HELP OUR STATE TRANSITION TO
UNIVERSAL MAIL. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING FOR
UNIVERSAL PRACTICE MARGIN OUT
OF SCHOOL TIME MEALS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET GINGER
WE'RE PROVIDING HEALTHY FRESHLY
PREPARED MEALS TO ALL STUDENTS
NO MATTER THEIR INCOME LEVEL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR MEXICO. WELL THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING HOW HIGHLAND
ON THE AFTER THAT THE PDP
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE EIGHTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CGPA THEY'LL PUT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PANDEMIC
WELL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICE OF THE U. CATION CHARTER
SCHOOLS GP THE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THESE FUNDS BECAUSE THE
STATE DOES NOT RECOGNIZE RGP
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
THE FUNDING IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE HE TAKEN. CALLED
FARMWORKERS PROGRAM FUNDS WHICH
ARE PROGRAMMATIC FUND THAT WE
USED TO RELY ON AND MAINTAIN
AND DEVELOP HIGH QUALITY P. P.
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS HE TAKING
SHAPE YOU STILL NEED TO
CULTURAL WORKFORCE PROGRAM ARE
GREATLY IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
PAID INVESTMENT THAT WE ASK
THOSE PROGRAMS SPROUT A MINIMUM
TO RECEIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINES
FOUR. GOOD MORNING SHARE NUMBER
LET'S AND BEHALF CATCH LEARN
FOR LOOK A LITTLE WE TO DONATE
TECH AND EMPOWER FIRST TOWARD
UNIVERSE SCHOOL HOW TO TRAINING
THE QUESTION R. AS SHOW THAT IT
FALLS SHORT AS ABOUT 50% OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
BENEFITS CALL ME OLD FOR ALL
WHICH WILL HELP PROGRAMS
CONTINUING TO STRUGGLE WITH
ALSO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE. RELIEF
OKAY TO WORKING WITH YOU RING
IN. FOR THANK YOU VERY THANK
YOU VERY. MODERATOR CALLER. THE
LION SEVEN. THIS IS ROBIN
LAYTON EDUCATIONAL RICHARD
DISTURBANCE NBA GO AND I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROBLEM THE COUNCIL THAT WAS
THAT FORMED LAST YEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR I SUPPORT RATE REFORM
AND- CONTINUATION OF THE HOME
POPULOUS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING US THAT IN THAT THE
HOLD HARMLESS ALLOWED US TO BE
OPEN FOR IN PERSON LEARNING
THIS YEAR PRESIDENTIAL WORKERS
WHEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE
CLOSED AYE OPPOSED TO G. K.
PROPOSAL S. U. S. B. P. HAS
BEEN DOING WHAT THE CDP SAID IS
NEEDED FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS
JUST BECAUSE THE S. P. P. THE
RATE FOR CALLS FOR T. K. I HAVE
NEVER AND I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
ONE MEMBER OF THE POLICY
COUNCIL PROPOSED. HE K. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I SUBMITTED
MORE IN WRITING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL. WHY
THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY THIS IS NANCY WHY IT WOULD
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD CARE
NETWORK IF THE PARENTS ON THE
WAITING LIST FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PLANS
FUNDING FOR THEIR FOUR YEAR OLD
AND NOT. ALWAYS UNDER FUNDED
DON'T TAKE CREE QUE EVEN IF
IT'S NOT THEIR FIRST CHOICE.
AND THEY GO OFTEN GO CRYING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THEIR CHILD LEAVE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT FUNDING IS THAT
STILL REMAINS AVAILABLE FOR
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PLAN I KNOW
THAT NOT. ON YOUR CD E. RIGHT
NOW BUT BASS THE WAIT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL ENCOURAGE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU.
FOR THAT WILL BE FROM LINE
FORTY YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE.
EMILY ROSENBERGER AS THE IDEAL
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENT ON SCHOOL
NUTRITION AND CLASSIFIED FROM A
PROGRAMMING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT CSEA- ON BEHALF OF CCPO WE
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT- PER
CHILD CARE THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE TV PROPOSAL
WITHOUT. UNNECESSARY
STABILIZING THE CORPORATE IN
THE R. THREE AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROVIDERS WELL WE
HAVE THOSE IN WRITING BUT WE
WOULD REALLY URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUSH FOR- THE
BARGAINING TO HAPPEN AT THE
TABLE. TO REACH A FIFTY P. YOU
CONTACT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
PARDON ME THAT WILL COME FROM
NINE FORTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING KELLY REYNOLDS ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA EARLIER DEPOSIT
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR BOULDER
GRANTED IF HE CAME THE PROPOSAL
WE ALSO ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAKING EQUALLY
BORDERS ETHNIC CROSS ARE EASY
TO STAND. BY ADOPTING EASY
COALITION I REQUEST YOU. TO
POTENTIALLY FIND MORE CHILD
CARE SLOTS INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT
PROVIDERS TO JUSTLY COMPENSATED.
WE ALSO AFTER THE LETTER
CONSIDER POLICY DOESN'T CREATE
PROGRAM TO STABILIZE AND
STRENGTHEN EASY SYSTEM AS
OPPOSED THAT BECAUSE- THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PER SHARE
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
LINE THIRTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
MICHELLE MCGEE UNDERWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION I WILL BE QUICK AND
BETTER ELOQUENT NEED MORE FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE BELIEVE
THAT THEY DESERVE MEDICAL LAST
JUST LIKE THE L. B. AFFECT WE
ARE CALLING FOR ONGOING FUNDING
FOR PRESCHOOLERS WITH
DISABILITIES THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS A
RECOMMENDATION ARAMBULA FUNDING
STREAM THAT WE SUPPORT. AND WE
ALSO REQUEST BILLION DOLLARS BE
TARGETED TOWARD STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES FOR THEIR. BETTER
LEARNING. AND THAT WILL
SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY NINE FIFTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MUCH YOUR KIND MODERATOR CALL.
LINE FOR ONE. MEMBERS
INTERCHANGE IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS I'LL
JUST QUICKLY ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE OTHER SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL SUPPORTERS AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT BY ICV EAT OTHER
JUST NOTE THAT THERE WAS A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
GROUPS WHO- WELL IN COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS INCLUDING
ALL FORTY ONE OFTHE BANKS
THANKYOU. THANK YOU FOR SAVING
US A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
OTHER CALLS WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING SURELY DOWN BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WITH MICROLINER
COMMENTS AT THE CHAIR OTHER
LEADS THE DEFERRALS AND
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ONE TIME
FUNDING THE FIRST COOP PANK THE
THING THAT THE FOR TREATING NEW
PROGRAMS AND EXPANDING EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE ALSO WANTED TO ADD
TO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND JUST ADD
THAT I'M MOST OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING WITHOUT THE TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS AND NOW MOST OF THE
COMEDY. REPUBLICANS GOING
PREDOMINATELY CONCENTRATION
GRANT CREATING A LOT OF ONE
TIME FUNDING- AND COMPETITIVE
PROGRAMS EXACERBATE THE ISSUE
OF FINDING FOR THE HAVES AND
HAVE NOTS WE JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS DISTRICTS THAT HAVE FULL
TIME GRANT WRITERS TO RECEIVE
THIS FUNDING WERE SMALL AND
ROLES DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS TO
THAT WE ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH. LAUNCH WE-
YOUR CALL. AND YOU CAN REFER
ANNEX. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
PINE TO EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF FLOCK
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS REGARDING RETIRING THE
FULL AMOUNT OF THE DEFERRAL AND
WE WOULD REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER A
FUNDING APPROACH THAT ALLOWS
ALL UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAMS
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISED
RATHER THAN USING CONCENTRATION
FACTOR. AND ALSO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
REGARDING THE FIVE POINT 007%
COLA BEING APPLIED TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. YES SIR THAT WILL
COME FROM LINE TWENTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AND WE COULD WATCH
A REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME ON
UNIVERSAL T. K. ALL LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT COULD DANGLE AND EARLY
EDGE. AND JUST VERGE A
COMPROMISE THAT INCORPORATES
UNIVERSITY CAME THE FINAL
BUDGET- I ENTERED THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY I DO WANT TO
KNOW THAT SAN DIEGO UNIFIED HAS
PROVIDED HIGH QUALITY
INDEPENDENT STUDY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE OFFERING THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. TO THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR AND WE ALSO JUST
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE COLA- THAT HE'S PROPOSING I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
BLIND FORTY THREE AHEAD PLEASE.
AT CARE MEMBERS KATHY VAN
OSTERN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA-
JUST CALLING TO SUPPORT- THE
PROPOSAL FOR G. K. AND WE JUST
ENCOURAGE THE- BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND POLICY
COMMITTEES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE THAT BALANCE FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND CHILD CARE PROGRAM
JOHN DONVAN RANGE TODAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE ELEVEN. WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER WHEN CHILDREN ARE
CARED FOR THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- RAISING QUESTIONS
ABOUT PARENTAL CHOICE AND HOW
THE PROGRAM TOWARD GETTING I'M
TRYING TO LIKE GO WITH THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER EARLY
EDUCATORS WANT TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATORS DEVELOP A
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT IS BASED
ON GOOD NIKOLAEV REMODEL TO
MEDITATE THAT IS WHY WE ARE
ASKING FOR A PAUSE TO CREATE A
MORE SIMPLISTIC WORKING FOR
CHILDREN AND INCLUDED THAT
BIRTH YOUR CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
HAVE BEEN OPERATING TO CARE FOR
OUR CHILDREN ESPECIALLY IN THE
LAST YEAR AND THEN WE'LL FOLLOW
UP WITH WRITTEN COMMENTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. LINE TO NINE. THE BOARD
BUT THE CAL SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION WE APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S FUNDING PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY BE
RECEIVED BY CONCENTRATION GRANT
DISTRICTS WE AGREE WITH THE
GOALS OF THE PROPOSALS TO
PROVIDE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT WE ALSO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STUDENTS
ARE LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT IN A CONCENTRATION
GRANT DISTRICT WE REQUEST A
SUBCOMMITTEE EXPLORE PROVIDING
THESE FUNDS TO ALL ENDED THE
CAGE STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR DISTRICTS CONCENTRATION
GRANT. STATUS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
MODERATOR YOU HAD INDICATED
THERE WERE NINETEEN PEOPLE ON
THE LINE AND THAT WAS JST
NINETEEN CALLERS- HOW MANY MORE
DO YOU CHAU QUEUED UP AT THIS
POINT. EARLY THEREAFTER MORE IN
Q. THEN WELL JUST BARELY MAKE
IT SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO TAKE
THOSE THIRTEEN AND THAT'S IT SO
THIRTY SECONDS EACH LET'S GO
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. PINE FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION- TO BRIEF COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPAGANDHI
EIGHT FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOCUSED ON SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT SECOND WE ARE
REQUESTING AN EXTENSION OF ONE
YEAR ON THE EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS FOR COUNTY OPERATED
COURT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS WE DO NOT
GET THE SAME STATUTORY
PROTECTION THAT. UNDERMINING
ENROLLMENT THAT DISTRICTS DO SO
WOULD APPRECIATE THIS AS WE
HAVE SEEN A DROP AND-
INVOLVEMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
BLIND FORTY EIGHT. MISTER
CALDERON BIRTH OF ERIN AND THEN
BOND BEHALF OF THE FELT AND
MINISTRY THERE'S A CALIFORNIA
WE APPRECIATE THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION INVESTMENTS PROPOSED
IN REMAIN REVISED AND ALIGN
MOST OF OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION WE ALSO
THINK ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE COBIT NINETEEN PRESSURE
EDUCATION FIND AT PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
CONVENIENT AB EIGHT NINE SIXTY
SEVEN. THE FUND WOULD PROVIDE
FOR DIRECT SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
EQUITABLE OUTREACH TO FAMILIES
AND ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION TO QUICKLY ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
MITIGATE THE COSTS. ARE LEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
FOUR NINE. HELLO THIS IS A
THAT'S BEEN WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR QUALITY EARLY LEARNING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION
TO EARLY EDUCATION WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN BILL
AND THE IMPACTS ON LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WHO TODAY RELY ON FULL
DAY CARE HELLO ALL YEAR LONG
AND WE ARE ASKING FOR A PROBLEM
THE BILL FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS
THE FAMILIES AND THE PROVIDERS
THAT PAYROLL NEXT CAN BE HEARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. BY. TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
VALERIE DINERO WITH EVERY HOW
CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN OUR
CONNECTIVITY EASY COALITION AND
WE SUBMITTED A WRITTEN COMMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE HIGHLIGHT THAT WERE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO YEAR SUPPORT OF THE
RATE REFORM EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FUNDING FLEXIBILITY
AND LASTLY WHAT'S THE POINT OF
A PARENTAL TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
PRETTY ELIGIBLE CHILDREN THANK
YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE FORTY
SIX. HI KATIE HARTMAN AT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE SUPPORT MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE MAYOR VISION
BUT WE ALSO WANT URGED BY
DEEPLY CHURCH YOU ACCESS YOUR
APP CALCULATION IN THE BUDGET
WHICH HAS ABOUT A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR IMPACT ON THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT LEVEL
ANNUALLY THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. PINE FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU MICHAEL SAYS- ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SERVING A HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND STUDENTS WE WANT TO
ALIGN OUR CARE OUR OUR COMMENTS
FIRST OF ALL WITH CHEERS
CONCERNS ABOUT DEFERRALS WE
SUPPORT DEFERRAL ELIMINATION
WANT TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE COMMENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY
ABOUT THE NEED TO EXTEND FOR
ONE MORE YEAR TO HOLD HARMLESS
ON COURT COMMUNITY SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT THERE'S BEEN A
DRAMATIC DROP- TO THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND COMMUNITY SCHOOL
EXPANSION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR. COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR JAMIE
MODEL HIGHWAYS HEADSTART
CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE EPA COALITION
IS BUDGET REQUEST AND OFFER THE
COMMENTS FROM P. E. ABOUT
COOPERATING AND COLLABORATING
WITH HEAD START AS WE SPEAK
MOVE BOARD AND IF K. WEREN'T
ENOUGH THE BUDGET SHOULD
GUARANTEE PARENTS CHOICE BY
MAKING EQUITABLE INVESTMENTS IN
THE CAPACITY OF THE NEXT
DELIVERY SYSTEM INCLUDING HEAD
START AND I PRETTY BY REQUIRING
THE PARTICIPATION OF ALL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AGAIN
INCLUDING HEAD START INTO
PLANNING. WE HAVE THIS IN
WRITING AND WE LOOK AT OUR
FEATHER COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT PER SHARE
YOUR. COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. BY FIFTY TWO. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON MARTHA'S GOES DS REP
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION WE ARE
THINKING COMMITTEE SUPPORT- THE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR THE
BILINGUAL TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THIS
PROGRAM IS A GROW YOUR OWN
APPROACH WAS PURPOSES TO
ADDRESS A BILINGUAL TEACHER
SHORTAGE WITHIN A LOCAL AND
REGIONAL CONTACT FUNDING THE
PROGRAM WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF BILINGUAL TEACHERS
ALLOWING FOR INCREASED
OPPORTUNITIES BY OUR STUDENTS
WHO. ARE MULTI LINGUAL AND
BILINGUAL PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT COLON.
LATER. SEVEN THE MORNING THERE
ARE LOADS OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ONE THAT VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S FOCUSED ON
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND
INVESTING IN THE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE GREATER NEEDS BUT WE SHARE
THE CONCERN OF ENSURING THAT
THE THUNDER ACTUALLY GETTING TO
AS BENEFITING THE STUDENTS TO
THAT AND- WE WOULDN'T. BIKE TO
REINFORCE THE INVESTMENT AND
THE L. CAP PORTAL AND REALLY I
CREATING GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY HOW FUNDS ARE
BEING HANDED HE ALSO SUPPORT
THE INVESTMENT IN A MORE WELL
SUPPORTED IN THE FIRST TEACHER
PIPELINE- BUT AGAIN WOULD
RECOMMEND A MORE GUIDANCE ON A
LOCAL PLANNING PROPERTY SO THAT
THE MONEY COULD ACTUALLY MEET
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS AND EXTENDING THAT
TIMELINE OF. EDUCATOR TECHNIQUE
GRANT. THANK LONGER IMPACTED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR-
THE MODERATOR NEXT. BLIGHTED
FIFTY. THE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN IN
NEED IN THE CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING AND
GROWING EXPANDED LEARNING AND
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
ADDS EXPANDED MINING PROVIDED
AN ADVOCATE WE ASK THE LEADERS
TO ENSURE THREE TEACHING ST ONE
ADEQUATE- PEOPLE FINDING DAILY.
RATE FOR ALL STATE AND
FEDERALLY FUNDED OUT. SCHOOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE THEM
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. LINE FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU CANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA.
CITED THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDED I REQUEST FOR THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE CREATION OF AN
LGBTQ CLASS TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF I
BELIEVE THAT MENTIONED AN ISSUE
SEVEN AND THIS WILL BE AN
EQUITABLE AND EFFECTIVE TOOL
THAT CAN BE SCALED ACROSS THE
STATE AND THIS IS THE PRODUCT
OF EIGHT YEARS OF ADVOCACY LED
BY EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. OF
COURSE INCLUDE PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LGBTQ CAUCUS THAT WE
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADVANCE FUNDING AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS A MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
MISTER NUMBERS STORED BEHALF OF
NOW LIVE AT THE PO MICHAEL ON
ISSUES IN A DISCOURSE CENTER
COULD ABOUT THE EQUITABLE TO OF
WEALTH A OPTIONS CRAMPONS AND
THE HOLD HARMLESS. IN ADDITION
THE CRISP TO THE ISSUE THREE I
NOTE THAT THERE'S NO. TO TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS LESS THAN
DISTRICTS RECEIVED WELCOME.
PERHAPS IN CLOSING ALL THE THAT
ARE TO THE LARGEST TURNS
THERE'S CLEARLY. ON THE INCOMES
ENGAGEMENT PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU AS WELL
FOR CALLING YOU VERY MUCH. MUCH
FOR YOU HAVE A MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. AT THE ALWAYS HAVE ONCE
SAID IN CENTER MANAGE DROPPED
OFF. ALL OF MY THAN. CALLER IS
A LAST CALL- Q. THEM UP.
RELATED TO SAY GOT PLEASE. WOW
THANK YOU SENATOR AND MEMBER
PAMELA AGAINST REPRESENTING THE
LOSS AND CA OFFICE OF. FIRST OF
ALL OF MY TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR HIS CAR WERE CUT THE TICKET
PROPOSAL AND- B. OPTIONS OF
CHOICE AND ALSO ON THE THAT SHE
IS P. M. MAY RETIRED. FOR THE
WORKING WITH THAT AFTER GOING
FORWARD AND WE HAVE BEEN. I'D
LIKE ALSO LEVEL TWO AND HAD
START WE ALSO WANT TO LEARN
IT'S ALSO COMMENTS RELATED TO
HARM FOR THE COUNTY COMMUNITIES
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH N. MODERATOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TO. WE OR SHE YOU
BY WITH- TRY SIR IS WE CLOSE
HEARING ON ME ASK ARE THERE ANY
AND FROM OF THE MEMBERS. BUDGET
IN FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT THE WEBSITE. ARE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL RECORD. THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR FORBEARANCE AND
YOUR PARTICIPATION. AND THANKS
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE COVERED A
LOT OF GROUND TODAY WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED. JOHN.